dealing with these four uh bills which
are addressing the adequacy or swep and
um today we're going to try to come out
of here with some recommendations on all
four bills for the subcommittee members
to take back to the policy Committee in
education which then we'll probably go
through the same discussion on the
education
committee so I want to go through the
paperwork that was just handed out to
make sure everybody has a
copy uh does everybody now the sheets
which just have just been passed out
there are several sheets which
reflect the formula how it was done with
the esbrook study back in 2008 for the
base cost and so there's one sheet there
which you can see on the back side where
it has the uh recommended uh base cost
the universal cost at 4,000 on the first
sheet in the top $4
4,529 that you if you have that sheet
that's not the one with the scratch outs
that's the
one stapled it's stapled that's right
and there's more in that packet there's
also attach that packet um some two
tables on the next sheet in that packet
which
reflect top one is a uh some information
that I got from the director of uh
special education at the doe uh director
fet and below it there's uh some further
information which takes the total cost
of these three categories we'll be
addressing them uh on the third sheet in
that packet
IT addresses the um issue of of uh the
weighted for special education in the
that in the old formula but it gives
three weights um based upon the base
cost on the per sheet of
$4,525 and we'll discuss that and the
the last one addresses the issue of the
base cost of
$10,000 which if something came out
that's how we probably make some changes
the other sheet which you have here this
one the difference between this one and
the one you just looked at is that and
the one you looked at first when you go
right to the top of it and that stapled
copy you can see the ratio K through 2
has been changed to 1 to 23 St and and
right now it's 1 to 25 based upon that
old formula U that one where where we
came out with that Universal cost of
4529 um is built on a ratio 1 to 23 and
a ratio 1 to 28 the one that's crossed
out is based upon everything the way it
is in that 2008 report 1 to 25 1 to 30
and you see by doing that but the same
salary is at the top of it the the
outcome would drop it down in amount for
base cost to
$444 um the we'll be talking about these
how the the initial salary was gotten
the
$2,560 how that was gotten uh arrived at
which is statistically generated and the
other sheets which you see uh I think
you'll see this sheet right here we'll
be talking about it um it's the one that
deals with the um base cost if we used
$444 um and there's supported data
attached to that one so this is some
information that's we we should discuss
here today before we take any action on
anything um and then uh there should be
also a sheet that you receive like this
which are the revenues which were
provided to finance yesterday what's in
the education trust
fund they where where the sources of
those revenues are and where in the
Appropriations so that I'm sure
uh represent em was discussing yesterday
and representative Heath and um there's
another sheet which you should have this
one was just provided to us by
representative fellows and it looks
going back further than 2008 to 2004 and
deals with the fiscal capacity disparity
I call that that the name for represent
FAL you say was targeted a so but we
will at that when we want to look at
this we'll invite representative um
fellows up as she was working at doe at
this time I'm familiar with
it okay and also we have asked to come
forward to this meeting Mark is here
from the Department you have some
spreadsheets for us also so I'd like to
go through your spreadsheets first Mark
so then if you want to clear out you can
clear out but um do you have those
spreadsheets available for
us yeah why don't we come on up and take
care of that stuff I does everybody have
a copy of these four bills in your
packet of materials you should have
those and also there was another
information which we did have I passed
out one meeting I'm going to show you
that because we'll be referencing
referencing this during the course of
our discussion there was a sheet which
we had that we had data data provided to
us by research here in the house it has
the where we got this cost for the the
starting salary of a teacher in the
state of New Hampshire which is $
42,5 7 and it identifies all the
districts in the state and what their
their contracted levels are at and where
they're starting so you can see there's
a number of them which are starting much
lower than that figure unfortunately and
some that are above it so this is the
average of that so we'll be referencing
that sheet when we talk about some of
the other
stuff I thought I had handed out this
once before I don't see that in my
packet okay Jen can we get copies made
of this I'll take down yeah because it
it lists all the districts within it too
from the high to the
low
yeah okay okay we're getting
some I wish I had a copy machine like
that yeah yes thank
you as you look over this I just want
to you know I was asked to look at the
Formula and try to modernize it and U
I'll just prose this by this is kind of
more of an academic
exercise cut school funding by 200
million so I don't think it's going to
be something that you're interested in
but but as an academic exercise talk
about it some of the concepts yeah
that's what we like to talk these
Concepts
involved the old
formula is very
targeted so that's just how it was
in
so just looking at the big spreadsheet
um couple things to point
out
um this has median family income which
is not how we use we don't use median
family income in the current Formula um
median family income is used to sort of
identify towns that might be wealthy
meaning um it bars any town that has an
equalized valuation per pupil um over
the state average and it bars um you
have to if you meet that condition so
your evpp is over over the state average
meaning you have a lot of property
wealth relative to students and if your
median family income is above
150% of median U 150% of the median
family income um if your community is
you're barred from targeted Aid targeted
Aid is the last section of this formula
so it was used as a vehicle to a
mechanism to identify communities that
had high income and borrow them from the
formula uh I will say this as I look I I
got this data from Phil Lenton with the
fiscal policy Institute if you want to
dive into this data in more detail I
would recommend bringing in Phil slon um
my how do you say name Phil slon s l
tteen so um talking with Phil a little
bit and he can speak in more detail he
said his concerns are the margin of
error in this data and so Statewide when
you look at uh median family income in
New Hampshire it's
110k but the margin of error on average
is around 20K so that would mean in this
data said you would not be able to
delineate or distinguish between a
990,000 per year family and 130,000 year
per family and so when you're just kind
of looking over 150% above um maybe
maybe that doesn't that margin of error
isn't much of an issue but it seems kind
of just on its face a large issue as far
as you know if you met a family that
made 90k versus 130k you would think
there's a wide Gap there 40K um so that
that one of the challenges with this
data it's based on US Census Data has a
90% confidence interval um Phil slen can
talk about the statistics in more detail
but that margin of error is definitely
real and it's reflected um you're seeing
a number but that number has a margin of
error behind it that's uh pretty
substantial um but this 2008 Formula
does use median family income so the
section that's highlighted light blue is
the first there's three Aid components
there's actually a hold harmless in here
that I did not um try to recreate um but
this is um how big was that whole D it
wasn't very big not very big 24
28,000 million million yeah it wasn't it
wasn't stabilization size yeah it was it
was sort of small potatoes relative to
some of the bigger hold harmlessness
we've seen um so this this light blue
section is local tax capacity Aid and it
works really similar to fiscal capacity
disparity Aid um so basically what how
this part of the formula works is you
take your evpp so your equalized
valuation over property uh sorry
equalized valuation over pupils so
that's basically your tax base over how
many students you have and it looks it
gets the average the average currently
is around 1.5 million so each student
has about 1.5 million of a tax base um
uh for the state average and so if your
your community's evpp is below that
number so say you had a low tax base
relative to students say you're at
750k and the average is 100 1.5 million
then that diff variance is now measured
the difference between your number below
the average and the average so if we had
a community with a low um I'll pick on
uh Berlin is around 760k so just to make
the math easy um let's say it's 750k and
let's say the average is 1.5 million
because it's near 1.5 million so when we
get that number it's about 750k so we
get that 750k number and then we
multiply it by the average local Ed tax
rate which is $10 sorry but we we don't
time it times it by $10 per thousand
well we times it by a in the form of a
percentage so $10 per thousand is 1% so
we do 1% of that uh 1% of that variance
between the average evpp and Berland's
evpp and we get um around 7,500 per
student so that's the aid amount per
student they're going to get and then we
multiply it by uh the number of students
and that's how local tax capacity Aid
works so it's kind of similar to fiscal
capacity disparity Aid except since you
really depends on your evpp which is
what fiscal capacity disparity Aid it's
a different program it's local tax
capacity Aid because in the grant is
determined by the local spend the local
sorry the local tax effort so it's an
interesting concept um since it was
enacted in 2008 and now I'm using the
same exact formula I'm bringing you
today's terms um it's doubled in size so
in 2008 it was around 200 million we
also had a lot less property values back
then and so um the sort of neat thing
about this concept and we're studying
this kind of from an academic purpose um
as property values grow so say your evpp
became 2 million and you're you're
you're now Berlin and you're 50% of that
you would be 1 million so now the
variance is 1 million and if say you
times that by 1% you know you would have
a higher uh Aid amount per student so it
this formula has a decent float
mechanism in a sense it would float with
property growth um if you wanted to do
fiscal capacity disparity a as you
implemented it in 2021 um you have to
modify the grant amounts and you have to
modify evpp amount so um this formula as
a concept seems to achieve that sort of
fiscal capacity objective um in in in
modern format it seems to um I didn't
see any issues with it as far as
modernizing it I could I could use it as
is
um the only um thing I would when I was
thinking about how this could create
challenges is is
uh if there's a lot of federal money
coming in or local local taxes are up if
local taxes are up let's say let's say
local taxes are up high local taxes on
the on the communities are up that local
Ed average tax rate would increase which
would then increase state aid and if
state aid was increased um potentially
the tax rate would lower so it create
this kind of can you can Mark can you
tell us how this would impact a
community like Lincoln where where their
property values are high yeah but the
average income is probably low so of the
person working you know at the hourly
wage so Lincoln is considered has a has
a Rel their tax base relative to their
students is pretty
high yeah yeah Lincoln Lincoln does not
qualify for this because their equalized
valuation per student is 10 million so
just like fiscal capacity disparity a
Lincoln would not under however you conr
that construct that um Lincoln is
considered has a high tax base relative
to students and so fiscal capacity
disparity Aid doesn't apply to them
um they're also in the 2008 Formula
they're not eligible for targeted Aid
because their evpp is High um even
though Lincoln's median family
income Lincoln's median family income
let's
see 95k so just below average so uh just
below the state average yeah you know
within the margin of error but um yeah
that's so Lincoln doesn't qualify for
actually they they get a zero Grant I
believe
I look at this Mr chairman yes I so if
we were funding education based on an
income tax that would make a difference
for Lincoln but since the source of our
funds is property you have to go to the
question of what the valuation is yeah
there's that's that's why that
distinction right it depends on what
your source is if you're funding from
income then it makes a difference what
the average income is if you're sourcing
from property makes a difference what
the average property is and income
becomes
irrelevant yeah so um I know House
Education house finance has had those
policy discussions on when building
designing formulas what metric is most
important to you in determining it and
properties always in the conversation
and then typically also in the
conversation is fnr counts so that's how
we've done things currently um but yeah
that that that policy discussion is it
comes up
often yeah where where the two meet here
so we yeah yes represent
Ames um Mark I maybe you you spoke to
this but uh under the um old 2008
Formula there was the calculation that
was based on EVP P yep and then there
was a cut off that was based on income
medium income and so a town like
Brookline as I recall just like a your
updated data come come comes across as
very eligible for the targeted aid until
it hits the wall of ineligibility
for for targeted because it's got a high
median income yes yeah so the way I you
I pulled up an old law book and I and I
you know I didn't go through it like
multiple times normally if I really
wanted to vet this thing out and I would
do a lot of quality control but I
believe my understanding of the 2008 law
is the local tax Aid local Ed tax um uh
tax capacity Aid would be Brookline is
eligible for that um yeah but you're
right the targeted Aid is when you bring
in family income brookline's now out of
it and to take a bigger Town Bedford
which has a very high income um I don't
actually know brine will but Bedford
does and Bedford is eligible for the aid
until you hit
that nope you can't get it because your
income's too high right
mhm yeah Bedford is uh let's see where
effs at um yeah their income 176 U
medium family income so and that's where
we bump into this problem of uh the data
isn't good because you know the cut off
now well maybe they shouldn't be cut off
because uh maybe they're in that
20% absolutely yeah so if I if I I don't
have it in I mean I have it in my
computer but if I looked at the margin
of error on that Bedford data there's a
way to read it that they're eligible and
then there's a way to read because the
margin of error so yeah or they or
they're even further um I was actually
reading the income data they just um I
think they just gave up in Newcastle
they just said greater than
250k so um so to me it always made sense
to have that cut that that uh
firewall with so the wealthier towns
even though we don't have an income tax
um but they have other ways I may it's
easier to raise taxes perhaps in that or
property taxes in that Community than in
other communities maybe that's the idea
um and to have that cut off but then you
come up come up against this problem of
the data is not good and so you're using
something that has a big impact and uh
and it may be a maybe making a
mistake yeah um from my perspective
although we have a lot of problems with
the fnr data and struggles with the fnr
data it it rolls in a little bit cleaner
um than Census Data cuz census St is
based on survey um fnr data is backed by
um you know U documentation that the
student is eligible uh and we've had
these conversations for for years so
represent luno you had your thank you
very much Mr chair and thanks Mark for
again for your your um very complete
analysis here and and this is terrific I
wanted to follow up on something that
representative spillsbury said uh just a
few minutes ago and also last week too
where you where you sort of cautioned on
the average and which is which is really
important I think particularly when
looking at at household incomes uh
because while while the property
valuation of a of a community is
essentially the
community's ability to to access um
resources um a um the the income is not
done on a community basis it's really on
a a household by household basis because
there going to be a large variability
you know across um AC there may there's
going to be an average but there's going
to be a tremendous you know variability
uh on that and uh and I think it it it
goes back to I think something we've
we've talked about and it has been
incorporated into couple of these
proposals a um um low and moderate
income property tax you know relief
program that is very much income sort of
you know driven but um but you know at
the end of the day in New Hampshire and
and I think across most St States um
school funding you know maybe not to the
same degree we do here in New Hampshire
right now um does have a a large um um
um school school funding has a large
portion of school funding does come from
you know local property um taxes and uh
in New Hampshire you know we're at what
70% 75% coming from local property taxes
I think that's way higher than it than
it is on average but um but but being
able to to you know to do something here
that that uh and I think marks marks
laid it out particularly with with
fiscal capacity disparity and there's
different ways we can do fiscal capacity
topair I think Mark's got a great
example here where it was done on a more
of a sort of a a a um u a a local tax um
uh effort or minimum effort that
expected you know for for every
community based on what its ability to
access resources is and then a um uh a
targeted or directed low and moderate um
income property tax relief program that
then focuses in on on uh a an individual
household's ability to access their own
resources to put towards to put towards
that so so uh I I guess in the end what
I'm sort of saying is that that you know
the spread what whatever we end up doing
I think is going to have a fair degree
of complexity um uh to it and just as
what chair lad said you know you've got
Lincoln's a great
example I mean ton of vacation homes
property wealth but but but very much
average income and then you've got
Bedford as representative Ames was
talking about which is very high incomes
but you know Bedford I think is are they
the third we got a superintendent here
are they maybe the third largest
District in the state um no you've got
sorry der man oh Derry and Nash but
they're right there with five or six
thousand kids I think 5,000 I think
they're like yeah but that's yeah but
but you know lot of income lot of lot of
high average income but a lot of kids
which which puts a tremendous pre amount
of pressure on that equalized property
value per people so anyway sorry about
all the the stuff there but
SPS very interesting observations but I
would like to throw a few caveats in
um first it's true that there's a lot of
disparity within any Community between
the low income and the high income
within the community I think that's in
terms of
income but real estate values in a very
loose and indirect way are appr proxy
for incomes where incomes are high
property values are bit up where incomes
are low property values aren't well
supported so the property values are a
result of the total Expendable income
available to purchase and and service
and mortgage and so
on so when when we've chosen to use
property as our primary revenue Source
we basically go to a community and we
add up all of the
property um to create the grand list and
it's a pool right so the mill rate is is
derived from the pool and then it's
assigned proportionally to the
individual owner's property which
actually works out well and makes
sense
but one thing I'm very uncomfortable
with and uh there's a component of it in
is means testing attacks we means test a
lot of social programs right we say
you're going to get an EFA or you're
going to get a a whatever depending on
what your income level is and there's
cut offs it's pretty much common
practice but when you take something
like a property tax which is already
proportional and you're tax according to
the capacity to pay doesn't make much
sense to
me
uh 1586 I believe has a component does
it not oh it's it's your other build
does it I get 1586 has the swept reform
yeah and that's got the low income the
low and monit income is based on income
that you've got to have in order to pay
the property tax that's the idea that
they don't have your income is low then
you might not be able to pay the
property tax and then you might lose
your property so it's it's all related
to and I would contend that where that's
the case the real problem is that the
property tax is too
high right everyone acquires his own
home according to his means and then
it's taxed proportionately I think if we
unpeel it the real problem is too much
is writing on the property tax okay n
you know just Ju
directed only to the
state
not
y yeah fair
enough fair enough but the point I'm
trying to get to is is is when you find
yourself as a state on a policy level
having to make carve outs and means
testing you got to look at the
underlying problem which is that the
property tax is too high and in the
towns where it's more likely that there
would be a demand for a low uh income
credit those are the
towns where the burden is the greatest
okay I mean for example Charlestown and
Claremont my neighbor
absolutely pop out on the first page
without looking at all four pages I
think it would still be true if you
looked at all four pages they are just
so far out of the
norm that they represent a problem for
the entire Community to afford the
property tax not just for a select few
with you know some kind of measurable
low
income so um look at uh
the evpp I think it's a marvelous
measure it bakes in so many
things
um and
uh the evpp of Charlestown at
is half the average yeah that's that's
near the bottom and a quarter of many of
the of the others well I think that's an
example
and that that you know even though
you're a unifor rate to all property and
you've got got
some very
high difference in their incomes may be
much greater than the difference in
their
property something that that that you
somebody talk about you know property
values are like this but income the
income spread across proper much wider
so you've got much greater you know
disparity in terms of in terms of any
owner's ability to
to to pay on that effort unifor
properer
if I can just boil my comment down to to
one simple proposition and I know this
is fairly fundamental so it's hard to
get
there when you have a tax
source that creates such disparate
results that we go to the length of
charting it in a chart this complex with
this many
variables what you're really looking at
is that you've got too much writing on
that one Revenue
source and and I'm I'm trying to
redirect the conversation to how we
unburden real estate not to how we
rearrange it and then send State
subsidies to take account of it yeah
agree yeah right now we're jumping into
the revenue and we're getting no ways of
doing that I apologize for my
perspective stick to policy here I know
you both did but now let's get back to
where we are
Mark
y question I think in this chart you
don't the local rate local got here is
not equalized it is equalized yeah it's
um
okay there could be there could be an
error I'm I'm not sure um I intended to
do yeah that's what yeah uh it should be
it should be tax effort over unequalized
tax
base um one right
here uh so the the I know the top number
the top number is the one that matters
the one that you see next to your town
actually doesn't matter for the formula
it's just there
okay Mark do you have anything else on
on the spreadsheet here yeah I'll just
be quick um The yellow section is
similar to the local capacity Aid except
you take your EV average evpp without
utilities and then you take your
community's average evpp without
utilities and if you're under the
average whatever that variance is you
apply the apply the swep tax rate that
gets you the aid per pupil and then you
multiply by the pupil so it's doing
almost the same function as the uh light
blue column except it's based on
non-utility tax base and it's the swept
rate um lastly the targeted part
is uh again like we said like we said
it's it's it's saying if your evpp is
above the average if you have 150% above
the median family income um both of
those apply you're not eligible
and um then it has some targeted Aid
based on sped counts fnr counts English
language Learners and
transportation and um the law back then
said 3% or greater increase each year
and so I just applied the 3% for each of
the I think 16 years or some odd 16 um
some odd years to get up to the a modern
metric um the only sort of lesson I
think I learned from this is our formula
in 2008 was very targeted as you can see
um now and and the model we have
currently is a mix some targeted Aid on
the right side of the formula some
targeted Aid on the left side of the
formula relative to fnr and sped but
every student has a base a amount um
there's no base Aid amount on this
formula the closest thing to it is
transportation aid but communities with
High
evpp um and uh uh and family income uh
are bar are barred from it so there's no
base Aid Universal base Aid that every
Community gets in this formula that is
why Alton my understanding is why Alton
gets Z so some communities are not the
current Formula has a base a amount that
every Community is sort of guaranteed um
this formula was very targeted um so
just kind of a difference from back then
to now um and that's just I don't know
another sort of History lesson there but
that's um where' you get that figure
314 on on your transportation out of the
base so so and I don't even know
yeah well no it's from it's it's
actually coded in law in 2008 it says I
believe the number was 190 190 or
something so there's a number uh
hard-coded in law and I don't even know
if there was a I'm actually unsure if
there was an inflation metric to
increase that I actually I'd have to
look at the law more carefully I added
an inflation metric to it of 3% each
year and so that bumped it up to
314 but that was pre2 2008 study
committee that looked into
transportation I believe all of this
would have C been codified in yeah I
based upon back that era that was part
of was added into the universal cost for
a student and it was $362 I understand
but so yeah the methodology on how they
got here um I mean I wasn't here so
um someone might know it represented
fellows might know it
okay and this sheet right here it it's
just a a comparison with current law
between then and now yeah so it's $200
million uh decrease in school funding so
it's obviously not going to look
favorable to almost all communities um
um the only interesting thing was gtown
and Rochester I think do better
and they just have really high uh uh
they just have the local tax capacity a
is really I believe benefiting them um
maybe more so than the current Formula
that relies a lot fnr data so um gol so
for example golf toown has a pretty low
poverty rate they have about a 15%
poverty rate the state average is around
25% so our current Formula puts more
weight on poverty um and so this formula
doesn't and so they do a little bit
better in this formula but that's that's
the only sort of compare and contrast I
could kind of find just doing a quick
analysis looks like a number of towns
did like Portsmith and Manchester
yeah they lose all um well Manchester is
just a big city so whatever happens
happen everything is going to be large
whatever happens to Manchester um but
yeah this the uh my understanding too is
excess swept was in play so a town
community like Alton what their full
swept would go um uh would go to the
state and they would so that's fun
funding they currently get to fund their
schools um and that would be gone yeah
are there any further questions on this
one
just real quickk when you talk about the
rate 25 that is
that yes
185% uh yes so you saying it's 25% is
not used to be around 28% uh yeah it
floats in that it floats in that range
I'm not sure I don't last last time I
yeah
okay are there any further questions
from mark thank you very much took a
little bit of time to do this but
present some information yeah it's it's
always good I mean there's always useful
to know the history and yeah uh just
following you now Sally you presented
this other that you're you're going back
in history as well is there anything you
want to add to this or explain yours no
you want to explain yours okay come on
up
trying to trying to uh talk about two
different ones at the same time would
really be a
challenge
so so you all have um spreadsheet even
within my
own so this really dates
back
f504
yes so one of the things I did in the
past week is I did some research about
the availability of the and of um median
household um
value and median household
income which is data that comes from the
Census and back when back in 2004 the
data that was used was from the actual
10-year s
census and it was pretty good data
because in addition to working at the
Department of Education I was at census
taker twice in 1980 and 1990 and at that
time when you got to the smaller
communities like I worked in rumney and
in and Bridgewater they used the long
form census form which had huge numbers
of questions about income and all this
kind of stuff so that was pretty
accurate one of my concerns is that what
they do now and they've been doing for
20 years is they do sampling every year
and so every year you can see new data
on household income and um home
values but they also do every five years
they look at five years of data and they
average that and then they adjust for
inflation and so that's pretty good data
because it makes the you know whatever
however many they sample in one year I
don't know what it is but your sampling
pool is five times
bigger and Phil slon I understand is
concerned about the margin of error they
do have margins of error but we've been
using equalized
valuation and that at least the census
data has actual data equalized
valuation includes some
um objectivity issues
because there are just so many variables
and really somebody's making that
determination it's based on that
equalized valuation is all also based on
a sample the equalized valuation um is
calculated looking at the number of
properties in a town that are sold every
year and comparing their assessed value
to what it sells for and particularly
right now there are not many sales so
that's highly
variable you know with a large margin of
error so I think when it comes to school
funding you're going to have to deal
with you know you're going to have to
accept that there's going to be you know
some and nothing is precise I mean we'd
have to go to every single school look
at every single expenditure every single
student to really get some kind of
precise things so that's just my comment
on
that if I stop talking for a while it's
because I have an issue with my throat
and representative spillsbury knows you
don't want me to start coughing because
you know what that looks
like is this using current data in in
the 04 formula it's using the data
that's in the adequacy that um is
districts are receiving right
now so you're familiar with
ADM the median household income and the
owner this is owner
occupied
home or from the Census there's one
difference in here between fy4 and now I
switched it it used to be it was family
income and I'm using household instead
for a couple of reasons you know we were
talking about 20 years
ago and I think
that people who occupy a home are
different the composition is different
now I think we have a lot more um
unmarried people or unrelated people
living in a
home compared to percentage wise
compared to what it was 20 years ago
also the advantage of
using uh household income instead of
family is household income involves
every
occupied um residents whereas family is
a much smaller subpopulation of
that so here's the
premise look at the you look at the
household income you've got the state
average running across the top for
individual town just like
aworth you can see the income in column
B in column
C it says if they were to have an income
tax of 1 half of
1% how much would they have to pay so
that's column
C
then
um if that's if that's how much they
have to
pay when you when you compare it to the
home value what tax rate would that be
so for aworth if the tax rate was
$177 per
thousand they would pay
$4 so that's done for each
town then if we jump over to let's see
so the next the next step you're not
going to see a number for this but the
next step is apply that tax rate
$177 to the equalized
valuation and you raise a certain amount
of money which is just not it's it's in
the formula you just don't see it you
take that and you divide it by the ADM
in column A and that tells you how much
revenue per student that town can raise
can
raise and up at the top you see what the
average Statewide
is so you can see there's
a big
difference when you look down that
column at how much much revenue per
pupil and that can be affected by the
the things that affect that are the
income of the
household what the what the average home
value is and the equal the equalized
valuation and the number of students s
stop right there and let's look at a
particular town I'm looking at
Bridgewater okay you're you're up that
NE wood uh where we're talking
959 um
now if you go down along the lake if
you're on the lake side of the road your
property value is much higher than on
the other side of the road and the
incomes though of people on the other
side of the road are a lot of folks that
are just going up to Plymouth and
working hourly
wages so I I would particularly because
well the ones that are around the lake a
lot of those are are probably not owner
some are owner occupied but probably a
lot the majority of them is not I would
guess but they're not residents other
words well would would wouldn't you
guess that I would I would
assume that's the case yeah but I don't
know I I I I don't live there
so okay why don't you keep marching on
then oh okay well I mean that that's a
good example because the income is below
average
mhm the home
value it doesn't it looks like it's a
little be below the well these these are
not averages these are medians so one of
the things when you look at the home
values it's not going to be those houses
on the lake it's not going to be the
ones the trailer parks either this is in
the middle so it kind of you know takes
that part part out of the out of the
equation through through step e but when
you get to to um G it does come into
play
because um you're going to be applying
it to based on the size of the Town
based on the fact they only have 84
students that's a lot of property value
so that's when it comes back into to
play and that's why even though their
incomes are not very high their property
value is a little below average it's
probably a little on the high side for
the area but the revenue they can ra
raise is way way high so they're not
going to get any of this
Aid so it's all it can be any of those
factors that kick
in
so we've we've
determined through G what we've come up
with is kind of like the capacity for
each of these towns so one thing
um I saw it in
fy6 I don't know if we've seen it since
then there have sometimes been a
component of adequacy Aid that says this
is the part of money you have
so how are you going to distribute it
it's not like you know this much per
student and you come out with X
it's look at your students and whatever
factors but you only have so much to
distribute so that's how this was
developed I mean you can clearly you can
just use parts of this but it was set up
to only distribute a certain amount of
money and in fy4 it was only $10
million but you can put anything in
here so for the next step if you look at
H you take the state average revenue per
pupil and you multiply it by
two the reason for doing that is the
number that that is shows in that column
for the state
2500 um
is oh wait a minute just forget that
part the reason that it's two is because
if you didn't multiply it by two you
would only deal with funding the
everything that's below the median and
the premise for this is you might want
to you know fund some that are you know
not the top 10% but you want might want
to fund some that are above the
median so that's why it's multiplied by
two
so
um the next thing it does is it uses a
adjustment factor which is over un under
I that's a
percentage so so when you multipli the
state average by two instead of
$2,200 you get enough you get
$4,400 and you're going to compare that
to the individual town so the first one
would be
aworth comparing the state average of
4,400 um
dollars
to the
3,116 and um aworth is below that so
they wouldn't get any aid but if that's
all we did did then it would cost way
more than
$50,000 so to make to make it come down
to match how much money you have to
distribute that's where that adjustment
Factor comes in you multiply that
adjustment Factor by the state average
and by the town's um amount which is in
column
G so what you get when you do that the
individual
towns you get certain amounts per town
and then you
subract the
state which
is um the with the factor in it which is
the five
2,500 by the
local amount so let's look at Allenstown
so Allenstown local amount is
2017 but when you multiply it by that
6 and then subtract it from the state
average the difference is
309 I could I you know I could have
shown more steps but I just didn't do
that because it wouldn't fit on the page
very
well and then you just take the
um column I is just the
309 m
multiplied by the number of
students so we're there huh we are the
last
column is
just just an example of so you could see
like if you were trying to distribute
more money what it would be look like
but you can't use the numbers in the
state um across the top that uh 205 and
the would in the it would be different
but the result would be this what's
shown so any questions on on this
formula represent
AES it's not not really on the formul if
there's
text that explains the formula which I
don't think we have actually i' like to
get that and that's really my only
question I think this is interesting
background information that we should
retain and hold but I don't think we
need to if we can get representative
fellows here it only only
difference you know this says 10 10
million in here and also this had the
medium family instead so I can that
would be great before the end I can run
up and get copies of this thank you very
much represent luno so thanks and and
thanks Sly for um for um showing this I
just want to make sure I understand that
th this isn't a a complete um form this
is this is a fiscal capacity yeah oh
okay thank you yeah this is this like
stands alone I mean you can put this
formula this is just put it like not
even inadequacy right it's it's a it's a
supplemental
disparity um but I think actually isn't
part of what we have now inadequacy
absolutely absolutely yeah yeah so I
just want to so I separate component
yeah I didn't really want to call it the
formula so thank you so I mean it's got
some um mechanisms in here that could
actually even be applied to something
else you know the idea of like you know
if you if you only have a certain amount
of money to use most of the time what
you see is it's just pro-rated you know
give everybody 90% or something like
that how this works with that um I don't
I doesn't even have a name like a oh I
think it's called adjustment or
something the adjustment percent is
something that when you don't have
enough money to give
everybody what they would be entitled to
it reallocates the money to fewer of the
qualifiers
with most of
the um uh ret the amount that's retained
is higher for the ones with the greatest
need
so it's not just pro-rated you're take
you taking back from the ones that had
the had the least amount of Aid like per
student
and lower you know redistributing it you
know Distributing more to the the lower
ones M Mr chairman yes so it's going to
take me a bit of time to
absorb this going calm to calm and
reading
but fundamentally you're trying to find
a way of determining capacity to pay by
taking into account both household
income and property value and merging
them that's what you're trying to do yes
okay
Ines number of
students
represent
my understanding is that the equalized
values that are um available to us from
Dr uh were were determined April 1
2022 and that April 1
2024 we will finally get values as of
April 1 2023 we're looking at April 1
2022 values right now is that correct um
actually I wasn't 100% sure there
whatever equalized
valuations are in the FY 24 adequacy
because they might be that's
2022 which equalized evaluations are in
FY 24
adequacy I think it might be 21 would be
the 220
billion number now down 25 it's up to
310 million number well no no which year
of equal up to so I I think it's 21 but
I could be wrong it's either 21 or 22
it what
you see folks from Ways and Means really
get into this stuff well yeah yeah both
of you were there I
I actually keep forgetting to ask Mark
to please put the year on the column
total I can tell you how 25 works so
basically well which year is which year
of equal valuation is 25 25 I'll tell
you 25 Works 25 we have Let's see we
have the ms1 comes in in the fall of of
uh this is why yeah so ms1 came in the
fall of 20
the no sorry fall 22 then it was
equalized throughout the 8mon period so
that would have been the fall of 22 so
22 would represent
25 so this is
21 because this is this is FY
24 any more questions any more questions
thank you very much okay repr fellows um
and Jen's getting you the uh language um
could I ask at this point um we had a
lot of questions about the lawsuit um
with conal and we have the
superintendent here this morning and I
just thought this would be a great
opportunity I know she's a busy lady and
has a lot to do would it be okay if if
we were yeah but what we're going to do
first we're going to get into those two
bills right now the one 10 million the
other with 27s that will we'll have a
little bit of discussion on what we have
in front of us and then we'll be able to
have or uh give some impl we just ask if
she has a time to stay
though are you well set with time I just
I all right thank you
good okay what I'd like to do now is
discuss um where we are in terms of the
bill which we have before us which is
suggesting that the base cost be $10
million 10 10 $110,000 per pupil yeah 10
million would be a wonderful thing but
we don't have it we don't own oil wells
or gold mine
so with that I'd like to First Look at
the sheet that has the cross outs on it
this one right
here because what what what this sheet
does it looks at the the formula which
came out of
2008 and how we arrived at base
cost and you can see that there's uh
the salary of
$425 everybody should have that sheet
now which was delivered by uh Jennifer
4 this is the one that came around that
we asked to have copies
made and you can see uh that the on the
second page in it shows you what the
state average minimum is $
42560 and you can go down the sheet and
see all the towns which are above that
and on the last page you can start
seeing how they really di down um to you
know $
31,725
2560 and the way it was designed back in
those initial days in 2008 there was a
33% added on to it for benefits
associated with that contract and so
then you see the total teacher would
have been
$56,500 within the building is based
upon a 1 to 25 that's um basically how
the base cost has been derived ever
since we've never messed with this part
of the formula at all um other than the
bottom line figure which would be your
Universal
cost and so you can see how it is if
it's 1 to 25 for K through 12 then that
portion of the uh base cost would be
$2,264 special specialy teachers those
teachers like our PE teachers music
teachers Librarians add on this other
20% they there's five categories there
you have five preps during the course of
AOL week and so was $453 was added
on and it would be added on if we were
using the uh the new figure 42560 and
you can see what happens on the other
side the Slate there for grades 3
through 12 when you come back to the
bottom side after you add in all the
different components which were
established as contributing to the base
cost you can see that after you add in
the individuals custodians instructional
materials technology etc for K through
two it was 4,000 would be
$4,690 for grades 3 through 12 $
4,245 and you can see how the formula
comes up with a universal cost down
before how you get that Blended cost you
take the
4,698 for those three grade levels
multiply that by
three do the same thing for the 42 45
for the grades 4 through 10 you get to
42 45 multiply for to 12 and multiply
that by 10 because there's 10 grades
then divide that by the 13 total grades
and you came out this out was designed
you came out with 4,400 you would come
out with
4,454
I believe back in the days in 2008 it
was a little over
$3,400 so that that's uh that sheet
right there there's
um and we use that
sheet uh in if we're looking at the
other component of
$27,000 per pupil the base cost uh would
be um based upon the categories which we
had and that's also attached if you went
to the sheet with the stap in it
um and you went to the third sheet
down in that lower
table the lower
table you can see the total number of
students we'd have if we use weighted
formulas for the three categories a b
and c this is the same legislation that
came out education policy last year but
using the a different weighted amount of
the base cost to determine the amount of
money for the various categories for
example if you go to the top level there
you can see in the top table category a
has A6 of the base
cost and it shows the number of kids
that were in that according to what was
developed by the director of special
education and they have different
numbers than are in the the adequacy
formula the adequacy formula has a total
of
3,965 kids this is 28,6 126 they take a
one time in history to get their kids
one time the other cost the state uses
for adequat an average cost and so they
take a higher number of kids they have a
number of kids so um this formula has
been based off the bottom table the
total number of kids we have in special
education
3,965 if you took the amounts that we
have in category b a b and c the the
percentage the the percentage of the
base a0 6 a 1.2 or a 1.8 you can see
that here's where we would get the the
cost yes yeah looking
at I I'm in this no I'm looking at this
sheet right here which is
looking right up on that top sheet right
here on the top table
y not
mine you got different data it's.
five9 which
um where do we run
off no know I'm
talking there there were there are two
sheets that we
had
and yeah that that that sheet that one
one you're looking at is one which was
developed for uh if we had a ratio of 1
to
23 and a 1 to 28 this is the formula
based upon the pupil teacher ratio for
those grades of one 1 to 25
and
okay so we're
on it
the the the formula which had $
4,44 as a base cost has higher um uh
percentages for determining special
education then does the other sheet your
of course a larger amount on the base
cost in the other sheet when you're
talking about 1 to
28 and 1 to
23 Universal cost for that was
$4,500 this is $4,400 we working off of
so the base cost or excuse me the the
amount of money allocated for those
categories you could see how it is is
broken out by the the same ratio that
Rebecca fet did up a top when she had
28,6 26 students this is
3,965 we took the kind of same ratio and
project that in category C for example
in separate schools uh or in category C
for the the homebound the residential
and the separate schools that came up
with a lower number of Kids U than does
the one down
below yeah so how did how did you come
up with the um
looked at a lot of other states and
there are other states have SIM similar
type rate but we're also a hybrid that
in fact we have a separate category for
paying special Aid called catastrophic
Aid or special education Aid some of the
other states include that right right
within adequacy so special
categor it's aart from this formula
we're looking at so so I guess one of
the questions had the last we met last
we was in these three categories what is
our
Statewide yeah
right our Statewide actual cost to uh to
provide special education services for
all of the students Statewide are in and
and then do these $66 million no no no66
million
is what we have in the current Formula
no no right that's a funding that's not
that's that's that's not the cost of the
district that's the that's the funding
but you got to add in if you're looking
at the other component that comes the
state is saying we're going to give
districts 66 million the districts are
going to
thats making up the number a billion
dollar of cost and what is that what is
that all in District cost State plus
local
noal I'm not talk funds talking what
theost are the districts to provide
special education services to all
160,000 students across whatever
number of those students fall into
categories a b and c that
Statewide cost all
district 900 million
yes yeah we had that so if we're looking
at that 900 million then in the in the
in the one that we were just talking
about6 to 1.2 1.8 the the the total
funding by category comes out
so about of what the
district putting in a context like that
but there's a lot of downshifting coming
from the federal government too which
and we're asking the local to pick up
that burden and the state yeah yeah
which is a huge burden the the the money
we get from the federal government is
right it's under 20% now is it yeah 50
million so yeah yeah yeah terms of Rel
from the state I'm just trying to put it
in the Contex of what what our local
school districts are are spending so
local school dist spending $900 million
on all the students in a plus b plus C
and we
I'm this
spreadsheet says State might put 93
million towards that and there you know
yeah this this formula basically says
we're going to increase the amount of
money we're putting underneath special
education differentiated by about $35
million and then if you add the base
cost which this would also jump to
4,44 you're adding in
another go that next sheet I can get it
that's
yeah if
you if you
if you take what we're spending
for FY 25 for the base cost we are
spending
presently uh
million and with raising it that's at
four $
4,182 per
kid and then if we increase to 4,400
roughly
$444 it goes 680 so the difference there
is the $34,000 for the base cost the
base cost difference and the
differentiated Aid cost will be increase
of 35 so this is projecting that to
increase both the from the the the bill
that's the 10,000 per child in the 27
we'd be increasing the uh
additional Revenue needed to the formula
of $69
million
so that's therefore for discussion
purposes and that I I guess where we are
right now is that let's look at these
two bills which we have the 10 million
and the 27
million and and in conjunction with the
bill that you're putting forth represent
Ames and
yourself we've seen that that needs
interim study and there there there's
lots to do on that I I concur so we're
not ready to go there my concerns are
here we are going into
this next year when policy statements
are going to have to be sent out in
building a budget and we're not going to
have anything the foundation formula is
not going to be there yet because that's
going to be legislation submitted in the
next year that year so we could be
kicking the can down here and I'm not
interested in kicking the can down the
road I'd like to see some changes occur
one to reflect the actual cost of a
starting
teacher and to put in the in the formula
some weighted categories to support the
need for recognizing that it costs a
whole lot more Now speech therapists may
have 70 to 75 kids on their case load
that's pretty typical now throughout the
country and and the the case loads we
know might be a lot smaller for a a
student that is really handicapped in
needing lot of special care that's why
you see the C category B you know have
more allocated in the weight for funding
in differentiated Aid and C definitely
category C which yes it's not going to
get you that that three and a half times
and then the 20% on top that's
catastrophic aid but it's going to get
you closer to not having to raise as
much locally to meet those needs I
cannot see us jumping right into
something that's going to wholeheartedly
fund all this stuff in the next year and
so that's what I'm trying to do is
figure out is there a step we can move
forward to try to do something which is
based upon realistic figures you know
the the base cost would be built on the
minimum wage for a person starting out
in education and it's based upon these
contracts which we've seen right here
secondly on the weighted we need to wait
out I firmly believe that we need a
policy this will actually when we're
coming down later on to be discussing
the
program that's came out of the
commission they also recommended some
weight as they did for a lot of other
categories within it where special
education what so what you're what
you're talking about Mr chair are are
two two concepts
here B
the I
at sheet that
hases that that special
education special education
differentiated a would
be I'm not quite sure it's 93 million
the top part there table is based upon
not the number of kids which are
reflected we got to base on the bottom
one
right1 million
yeah then
next with theas going up 4182
444 it would have a net increase of base
of 69
[Music]
no oh okay are you going over
to yes yes
yes per
year so the by enemy would double it y
yep yep yeah that's exactly what this is
doing it's trying to
move the dial a little bit I recognize
this is not going to be funding
everything the way people really see the
need and and have the need in these
towns because they're having the raise
money still but this is moving the dial
and I think it's more realistic in terms
of really capturing those those dollars
in any kind of a a formula we have
coming at
us
yes I think that's a good direction to
go that's the first thing I want to say
to try to get something incre
incremental out the door so that there's
some immediate relief and that's what I
think you're pointing towards um the
what we're basing it on I think we all
should recognize is not is only a a
portion of real costs and um uh a good
illustration of that to my way of
thinking is that we're building off of
the minimum salary for the starting
teacher and in fact schools have a range
of teachers who've been there for long
periods of time so the average teacher
cost is significantly higher than that
um and so forth um so let's not pretend
it's other than that that to just react
to that or not react to it but that's
the way it was done and that was the
same question that came up back in the
days that the 08 was put together
absolutely and and so there's been
questions well should we pay taking on
the five-year teacher the three-year
teacher the and yeah that's always been
there but this is uh are some figures
that can be captured I'm not saying I'm
drilling down and saying this is the way
it should be but we need to base it upon
what is actually a a data point that is
realistic that's happening and this this
figure is based
upon data that we can justify it could
be could be
so I I I buy in to trying to work it
that way but I also want to
say uh that there is that that uh larger
context that's largely reality that
we'll hear from the superintendent on
perhaps um but the way that we need to
address that because it's really
complicated and uh there hasn't been
time in the last two weeks to do much of
anything other than shuffle through the
bills that have been assigned to us um
is to put the the 1586 as you've
suggested we will do into interim study
uh as well as I think the special ed
Reform Bill 1686 I don't know how these
numbers came out that way but uh anyway
um see both into interim study with the
idea that this will be a a serious
interim study and if I if I was a able
to make it happen I would I would uh
renew with the speaker's help um this
subcommittee as a way of uh boring in on
the what we have before us and the
opportunity that it presents and make
the best of it which may mean we come
out of uh out of that process with not
just one not just one single this is the
the way to go but a couple of or maybe
more more than a couple of ways to go we
have a limited pool of dollars that it's
not infinite and and when it comes to
Dollars allocated towards education yes
we have the money in the education trust
fund but but that's limited too and and
what we got to be cognizant of is
that when we're discussing these figures
right now my mind's sort of going blank
on me but um
it's the I I I'll come back I just lost
all my track I don't know how your mind
still works after what you've been
through for the last two weeksy
yeah it'll come to me yeah yeah so um so
we've got we've got two bills that could
be amended that would that would go
towards what you're what you're
proposing here with a um increas ining
the base to
4404 and then uh and then splitting out
the three categories for special
education differentiated Aid and the
total cost of that proposal would be
approximately $70 million correct okay
so so that's that's this right here and
what you what you handed out earlier
which I think Mr landeron had prepared
for finance yesterday shows
approximately $222 million estimated to
be um um I'm sorry at the end of this
fiscal year uh uh school year 2024 $182
million to be U remaining in the
education trust fund so you're about $70
million into that so my my concern and I
I lost track of us is back now when you
add more money into the
base we're not really putting
dollars on the right hand side of the
formula so I'm really hesitant of
jumping the base up to
6,000 5,000 or wherever we got to go
without a trying to D now when the two
categories we're affecting every
Community is going to be impacted
similarly with what these two things are
doing because that's they're all part of
adequacy differentiated Aid and that
it's not touching the other side of the
formula which needs to be addressed if
we're using the old formula Mr chair
we've done a lot of school funding stuff
together and I I know you know I'm with
you and I know you're with me on this
one so that I'm really hesitant of
jumping up that base because it's going
to be sending a lot of dollars out to
people that are
already keeping excess yeah but I think
what could be what I think what could be
very interesting though is if if we
looked at something like what you're
proposing here with about a $70 million
cost of of ba of base plus special
education categories and then something
like what representative fellows has
presented which I think is was just a
really a model and and could be you know
tightened up by the by the department
and and and Sally's got examples of a
essentially a a $50 million right-and
Side Package you know Aid package and
aund
million um you know package maybe
something between those two numbers that
comes in safely under what what Mr L
what the legislative budg budget
assistant is is estimating that might be
something that's within our our our
means is doable and moves the needle in
both the direction that that that the
court has suggested and or the court has
said has has ordered and um and
something that provides some Equity um
to our districts as well and property
tax
relief I I understand what you're
talking so you're you were talking about
somewhere putting another 70 million in
on top of this figure
and I just don't want to send something
on that's going to be dead upon arrival
but I'm saying you do it doing it doing
it through a through a fiscal capacity
disparity package not through a left-and
side package but through a right-and
side package making sure that it doesn't
eat into hold harmless and stuff like
that so that we're not penalizing it or
we're not I don't say penalizing that
where where it where it's where it's not
doing things where where it where it's
intended to to help and and I and I and
I guess what I'm really getting at is do
we have a a a bill yeah that could be
amended to do something like this or are
we out of
luck
we have one other one another swep in
the committee but that's we're out of
luck on that one I me we have a swep
here we also have yours um but that we
have the one that's the 10 and the 27
which deals
specifically with those areas of of
adequacy we're now sliding and the
committee's been tasked if you go back
and read the report that was put out by
I don't think I front of me right now
the by the speaker's office in
conjunction with the minority leaders
office we were to look at the formula
and recommended changes that can best
support where we need to go so somehow
it probably could be done uh we could
have a n a non gerine Umar it well or or
you could even use say that it's part of
the overall how we fund education yeah
we could use one of those bills to
address both base and differentiated a
sped use one of those bills to do the
other side of the formula
okay I would think that that would be
Germaine too I'm not the one that makes
that decision but we'd want to have a
hearing anyway certainly yeah yeah
because I don't me want to mess around
with the the one that's coming from
ardinger and you and you well it's from
from from and it comes out the
commission yeah I understand that and I
the SWAT bill
um that that that's that's not going to
go down party lines at all it's going to
go down Community lines and that's
that's a good way of killing something
too but you know we'll have to deal with
that one separately I I don't want to
mess with that right looking at looking
at these right here these bills have to
be out of committee February 14th we
will be acting on these bills on
February the 13th they have to be out of
committee on the 15th report reported by
the 15th
um so so if we're going to if we're
going to do anything with with with
amendments that needs to be done ASAP so
that we exactly right get see this has
to go back to the policy committee and
we're going to have to you know make
recommendations there for them to move
forward so
um yeah we're running out of time and we
also have the SWAT bill that deals with
gambling which is always a
tool um right but that's all that's
separate I'm just but that's the only
only fun other funding bill that I'm
recognizing we're in possession of yeah
okay we he yes we can do that now but
we're I wanted to hone in on this
discussion right here uh so
that we I'm I'm trying to get some sort
of idea where we're going and so that
the six people that are going to have to
make the final vote
here can do it and I don't know if it's
you know for you know if we have
accomplished what we need to accomplish
here I think I'd like to see us make
some kind of recommendation that special
ed differentiate be
weighted
period Well you know I I I think what we
need to do is conceptually we need to
say we believe that weighted formula is
very very important if you leave the
numbers out of it um I I think we'll get
unanimous consent throughout the policy
committee and it'll go on to finance uh
numbers can be put in it by us as well
but uh the commission recommended it um
and Most states do it and the base cost
I I think a recommendation needs if
we're we're working on the current
Formula we need to recommend that we we
allocate dollars with
in through that basee formula we have
here that are matched up what the cost
of an educator is today a teacher and it
sort of does that for the beginning year
it doesn't do it all the way but the
concept is moving that ball closer right
now we're funding at what 4186 something
like that that's below the 4,400 which
is up to what we're seeing as the
average we're F funding absolutely the
minimal
level of of of those that are paying 30
plus thousand per teacher starting well
I mean yeah yeah I mean I think there's
a there's a there's a lot to I mean if
we want to pick apart the sheet there's
a lot to pick apart on this but but I
but I but I agree with you
representative lad that that sticking
with what we could do is is a lot more
the funding commission or study that
we're looking at needs to really look at
inputs vers the other but also we need
to look at even if we are going to to if
we by chance stay with something like
this this is the other areas within this
may not be reflective of what it's like
in
2025 vers 2008 well I mean just the
benefits alone health insurance
retirement workers comp professional
development grad courses you know well
even when you're looking at okay where
where's the AI guy in there or you know
yeah
CIS the cost of doing technical stuff in
schools now a whole a lot more than it
was there but there's other needs too
that folks have mentioned to us that
aren't included in those inputs yeah
that we need to discuss as well same
real student teach student teacher
ratios too there's there's a lot of
stuff yeah but and so we'll never get
out of it if we right now that we don't
have time to do it right now that's
right so so my next question are um
what's what's our and I think it goes to
what Mel was asking what what do we need
to
what when is this committee going to
meet so that we can finish up our
immediate tasks leading to the February
15th got to be out of committee um and
then what's our what's the plan going
going forward
Beyond I asked a question what are we
going to do at another meeting this
group right here look at look at amended
language so next next week we'll get in
I just want to make sure I'm keeping up
with
you um it's my impression that what
you're suggesting is that 1583 be
amended with the figure
444 and that HP
1656 on the special ed be amended with
the three different categories each at
the uh figures that you have here 2642
that was one suggestion one another
suggestion is to
add both those TX pass on one of those
bills okay so variation on the theme but
but the point is to enact those two
propositions in one or two bills this
session to take effect with the next
banial budget commencing July 1st 25
giving direction that's where you're try
to finance to know this is what policy
is stating that we'd like to see
included in the next buying in budget
okay so so so the the cost of which
which would be an incremental $770
million
which I think sounds
manageable it wouldn't be for
fy2 yeah that's not the next bium budget
that's excuse
me FY exactly yeah so FY 26 but taking
effect July 1st 25 no taking effect July
1st
2024 well it's my understanding that
this is to take effect next year and
that's the way it's
drafted and I think that implementing it
starting the next budget then you can
manage for your revenues and and so on
on what I had in here
imposing where are July 1
2025 yeah I thought you were talking
about about taking effect for fy2 which
be July 1st
2024 no it it would take effect July 1
2023 because we've already established a
bud budget for
fy2 no yes yes we yes we have well we've
established the budget and the and the
preliminary you know estimates but but
not the uh not the well the
preliminaries don't even yeah the
preliminaries are coming out the actuals
won't come out until um till later this
year so if if I can just I was trying to
establish
uh that it's my understanding we're
talking about having this take effect
July 1st 25 so we commit to Something in
24 that takes effect in 25 for the next
budget cycle so I just wanted to point
out because I wasn't sure whether this
was
clear the summary we have in front of us
on the education trust fund shows a
cumulative ending balance at the end of
FY 23 of 161
at the end of 24
182 and at the end of 25 222 let's just
remember that's cumulative so you tap
into that you don't get to do it
recurringly year after year the
increment that's being contributed to
that accumulated balance is 20,
705 for 24 and 39 right
so
70 and another 70 um is way outside the
realm of what our current Revenue
structure would support 70 I think could
be accommodated so so so just to no I
think 70 plus 70 could be within it is
within the revenue structure because
we've got 182 million that is estimated
to be um to be the remainder in the
education trust fund on can't tap it
over and over no you can't tap it over
and over but when we go into the next
budget cycle remember we're going to
have a different legislature at that
point that that will also be able to
consider the um you know what the what
the you know how to fund the education
trust fund but can I just remind us all
that we currently have a bill that will
be going to the floor probably not this
week but next week that will drain the
education trust at the end of this
biennium
yeah I I just I I agree with this
understanding that the idea behind this
is a
oneshot infusion of money directed
according to these formulas to the
municipalities and um it will be
fashioned and drafted in such a way that
that's what it is it's a one shot it's
not a
continuing um
commitment and it would be taking effect
in uh uh for the next fiscal year
so fiscal year 25 that's my understand
starting that's what we're trying to do
starting July 1st 2024 yeah yeah
yeah
yes well I I I can see what we're doing
here uh my concern is the
lawsuit uh and
um we talked about kicking the can down
the
road and this is what we're proposing
here is another Bandit
uh perhaps it's a realistic Band-Aid
based upon our current fiscal uh
status but it doesn't deal I don't think
it deals with what the court suit
said and um now granted 1586 is an
attempt to try to deal this in a more
Global thing and I can understand why it
may be put into further study
Etc but I think there's an immediate
there's more of an immediate need I mean
that my that voice has to be in this
room and hasn't been in this room in
this
conversation and so I think that's my
frustration I mean we
created we created the
commission not to go back there but we
created the commission to try to finally
have a look after 40 Years of the data
that has been given to this to the
department for years we looked a 10-year
look first time in 40 years an outside
group came in and looked at it and they
gave us some
data now I know that that data is not
necessarily reflected in the
lawsuit but at some point in time we got
to deal with this
folks I mean the commission was created
because frankly the
legislature has not done its task on
what the court has asked for
has not done its task and we've tinkered
it here we've tinkered it there little
more money has gone out oh aren't we
happy we just did a little more
money and so that's I guess that's my
frustration of trying to deal with the
immediate issues
here but the long-term thing is still
sitting out
there and and I'm sorry I that's that's
my
frustration Celli but the long term
that's hanging out there we don't we
don't know because what we have is an
interim step from the courts there's
there's more Court uh review and action
down the road that's all pending too
okay I I really don't want to get into a
lot of discussion of the courts because
our task is not you know I understand
that and we all understand that and
think it all the time however our task
here specifically from leadership is
that we propose any changes to improve
the funding formula to
improve and and yes to improve this
funding formula we're a subcommittee we
have not had time even to scratch the
surface really in terms of the inputs or
the other performance outcome
methodology and we are scratching it yes
and that other bill but we don't have
resolution so we got to get there what
is the flight path from here to there
and are we just going to have this all
of a sudden Boop like that or we going
to try to build it and give some support
in in reflection to what we're actually
doing right now with our current formula
to we're not going to change just like
that no no but and to your to your point
uh Mr chair um we've got a report saying
that that it's estimated that the trust
fund will have $182 million at the end
of at the end of this year so J June
30th 2024 if we're talking of Band-Aid
which is is what you're proposing here
which I think is a a good Band-Aid
within the means that that we have I'm
also looking for some change no no no I
but but if we're going to do a Band-Aid
W with change into the the three
categories special education then then
we should put that in as soon as
possible within the means that we have
and we've got it right here $182 million
um uh apply this not for FY 26 not for
the next bium when there's going to be a
new legislature but for
fy2 put it in place for fy2 we can
afford to do that for FY 26 FY 27 the
next bium we're going to have a new
legislature and I think that new
legislature should absolutely be looking
at the work that we did back in 2020
should be looking at the work that this
committee does and to be thinking big in
terms of how we go about fixing school
funding which we know is broken but we
can't do that right now we can work
within this we can make some meaningful
improvements for our for our uh schools
and our taxpayers for
fy2 but the but the next legislature is
really going to have to not just be
kicking the can down the road but to but
to actually fix this so Mr chair can we
please hear from the superintendent from
the school district that all this is all
about just I think we really do need to
have some information you're welcome to
come forward and and present to us uh I
don't want to get in a whole lot of
discussion on these court cases though
I'm not going to go with conal or I'm
not going to go with binsky and all the
all that right now Rand I think what we
need to do is we need to have a plan to
move
forward and address some of the issues
we have a current Formula obviously that
uh needs some change now whether it's
with that report with some
other result you know maybe even
improving what we had because or maybe a
blend of the two maybe some of the
inputs have to be incorporated within
that which it can be done maybe we have
to look at that tax structure of some of
that that has to be done as well so I'm
all for doing what you're you're saying
however I just want to make sure that we
are recognizing saying yes we need if
we're going to have a formula that's
based upon the present formula the
formula has to move with the cost of
doing business as well and it hasn't and
the base cost has not been changed
significantly uh the cost of all the
people within that the the the
responsibilties transportation
maintenance hasn't changed looking at
new structures needed in schools it
doesn't reflect that that's what we need
to do I Concur and we also need to be
recognizing it cost a whole lot more to
educate a special education child with
differ handicapping conditions and we
want to have weighted this in in place
in the formula so what's been what's
been laid out today moves Us in the
right direction us right and we can do
it let's not wait to do it that's what
I'm okay welcome hi Rick how are you
fine I do not want your
job um so I am here because there seemed
to be sign some significant questions um
after I had left um testifying um in
support of HB 1583 about where that
$10,000 number came from couple of
things if I can react to some of the
things that have been said based on what
I know about the funding formula and how
much it cost toon a school district is
that if you just looked at CPI if you
didn't do anything else nothing if you
looked at CPI from the time from 2008 to
today just CPI and that's not the
municipal price index that's the
Consumer Price Index Municipal price
index tends to be a little
higher adequacy would be 5 thou would be
just above $5,000 so just as you're
thinking about I think it's great that
you're trying to take an interm step and
I think that that is the responsibility
of this group certainly you have a banum
budget and you have to work within that
and I certainly understand having to
work within a a type budget so the
$10,000 where did it come from so the
$10,000 is directly correlated to the
for the funding formula that was in 2008
we actually didn't Veer that far from it
we move we removed some things but what
we did do was we created a or did inputs
based on conservative real work costs
from across multiple districts
originally when when I did it the first
time we did just use conal but then we
adjusted those costs um and the first
place that we looked at we actually kept
the information around first year
teacher I don't have to tell you all
that you can't you cannot possibly fill
your entire building with a firste
teacher um and the average teacher
salary right now is is above
$65,000 so that's the average teacher
salary right now if you're looking at
average teacher salaries we also looked
at benefits those benefits that we are
legally obligated to provide now one of
the things that that certainly has been
been um purported is that well you could
offer less of a benefits package well
the
state benefits package is very similar
to the benefits package received by
teachers and those benefits are
absolutely necessary to recruit and
retain if we lower the
benefits we're going to have to increase
the salary in order to recruit and
retain teachers I don't need to tell you
that there's a teacher shortage because
you probably read about that regularly
that's a national teacher shortage not
just in New Hampshire so the next place
that we really and I think one of the
biggest places that we differentiate
ated was in class size versus ratio
those words get thrown around
interchangeably in this room I noticed
class ratio is very very
different than student or than class
size because while we talk about
specialty teachers and we talk about
those things we can't always have a
teacher in front of 25 students so if we
look at a high school for
instance and you think about okay we
have a 1 to 25 rati we're going to use
if we had a 1 to 25
ratio in a high
school teachers are
contractually entitled to a prep period
now you don't want to give them a prep
period you say that's part of the
contract negotiation okay let's we can
have that conversation minimally we are
required to provide them with a paid
lunch so while they're at their paid
paid lunch we still have to have
somebody in front of the children we
can't have all the teachers out in out
out at lunch at the same time and we
can't have all the students at lunch at
the same time because our cafeterias are
not that big that is not
possible and then of course you still
need teachers to watch the
students all right so maybe so we're
just at our paid lunch if you use the 1
to 25 or the 1 to 28 or the one to 30 if
you're using the 1 to 30 that's high
school grades 3 to 12 right that puts 40
children in a classroom with a
teacher you can't you you have to use
ratio you cannot use class size so when
we did the formula we looked at
historical ratios K to K12 they are 1 to
9.96 and 1 to in in 3 to 12 is 1 to 12.6
so we use ratios versus real ratios not
class size and that is a very important
distinction now I am not saying that 1.9
is ideal but we do live in a state that
is
rural okay my district in conell is 250
square miles we can consolidate with
other districts absolutely we could do
that so then instead of paying for the
classroom teacher and in instruction you
are paying for
transportation and you have to those the
trade-offs so yeah maybe we could get to
a 1 to 20 or a 1 to 25 ratio but the
size of those districts would be
significant and students would spend
significant time on school buses my
students regularly spend 45 minutes to
an hour on a school bus 250 square miles
buses Drive 3200 mil a day that's to
California so the next um place that we
we did look at that is different from
the formula are services that aren't
included necessarily um and and what you
have here um nursing
Services I um still remain shocked to
some of the response that was to nursing
services and I'm going to respect
Representatives lad's um con guidance at
the beginning I don't want to talk about
the court case but the bottom line is
you cannot have school in this day and
age without a nurse you have to have a
nurse NSE now I don't like that either
but the truth is we have students coming
to school that never came to school
before you cannot ask a teacher or an
admin assistant to provide the types of
medications to students that some of our
students require for instance the
medication for
severe severe seizures is given Rec can
I interrupt just for a second of course
you can and you have a question I'm
happy well I don't have a question but
we
recognize that uh nurse is a nurse is a
vital part of a school yep we're working
with the formula we have here you're
getting down into all those other inputs
and that's when you're talking ratio as
well I am just talking about where the
$10,000 came from that's why because we
and I agree with you Rick we added that
we added the nursing Services because
some of these services are not in their
optional and statute right now
um and and so we so if you have a child
who has a seizure disorder or I have a
child who is a type 1 diabetic that
child cannot receive an adequate
education or do any of those pieces that
call for an adequate education if that
nurse is not present if my I'm not
trying to argue with you I'm not
objecting to it but that results in
having a change statute right now got it
and so we that's not one of the bills
which we have in front of us and this is
why I'm saying this is just starting out
and we're going to have to look at all
these areas you're talking about great
and I I hear what you're saying I'm just
here to explain where the $10,000 number
came from um the other piece that and I
would ask you to consider is we removed
transportation and said that should be a
separate Grant so Transportation wasn't
even in the
$10,000 um and that is because if you
look so if we take transportation from
um in kentuk Valley that Transportation
cost per pupil about
$944 that does not include special ed
Transportation which I can't answer for
Mr Mello but um we don't we have about
$13 million in um special ed costs in
our district and that does not include
Transportation so
$944 another
District less rural cost
$421 and therein lies the problem
with the form with with that part of the
formula is right away that
$500 per
child creates a significant inequity
because money I have to spend and my the
taxpayers who live in the conville
school districts has to spend just to
get the child to school that other
place can spend on instruction
instruction materials teacher salary
nursing
services so there and and I think that
you are that this committee
realizes that that there's some some
very broken pieces
here what I think you really need to
consider is that that $10,000 is real
give yourself
Runway it's not there's no there's not
$10,000 in the budget I'm assuming if
there was I think that we would be
having a different conversation right
representative spillsbury there's not
$10,000 per student in this bium budget
to to to
pass 1583 but you do have the ability to
amend 1583 and say it takes effect on
such and such a date there is no
doubt and anyone who comes up here and
and wants to argue about base adequacy
and I've read the minutes from all the
way back to 2008 so I know
representative lad representative Miler
that you knew when you created the
formula that it wasn't enough
money there we know that base adequacy
which is the
floor for adequacy not minimum not
minimum not the bare minimum that is not
what the Constitution says in New
Hampshire that is not how it's been
interpreted it is adequate
is
$10,000 and if you want me to I what
what spreadsheets do you want me to show
you I I don't think you have to show us
anything seeing that we we recognize
that your your average teacher cost is
is is not 65 is
$67,000 we recognize there's a lot of
inputs which need to be addressed and
even added into the base cost we we get
that that's not going to be happening
right here today seeing that this is a
subcommittee looking at those bills and
but what has happened over the 35 years
is that every two years this happens and
everybody that's in this room because
I've read the minute says you're right
no I'm not I'm not sure that
representative cordelli has actually
ever said that it costs more money so I
forgive
me you're right it costs more money we
know that
and what I'm telling you what everything
that I have looked at related to this
and I have looked at all of the M
minutes I have looked at all of the
information I have looked at Sally
fellow's works I've looked at Mark's
work I've looked at everything because I
was I got grilled for three
days it cost
$10,000 actually
$992 we'd be happy with
that Court says $7,500 is the bare
minimum don't kick this down the road
because I have to and and I am not you
know I'm I'm I'm reaching the end of my
career I don't want to sit in any of
those chairs I have no interest in
that but what I can tell you is that if
you listened to newport's testimony if
you listen to Don magon your concern
shouldn't be the presid court case it
should be the one that's going to come
from the ACLU and parents because their
children aren receiving an adequate
education you have downshifted this
conversation to bare
minimum that is not what these decisions
have been
about it isn't about the bare minimum it
is about adequacy adequacy cost
$10,000 I I think and you know everybody
can say what they want about
I what was it um Advocate advocacy from
the judges I would remind you that the
judges have made the clar the judges
that made the Claremont decision pouring
into the court business right now John
sonunu do you have anything else for us
and not unless you have questions for me
it's clear that you you know that that
both the Ed committee and and this
committee are not particularly friendly
to to to what I have to say I I think
that you know again no matter what what
the numbers are no matter what you do
the bare the bare minimum if you want to
put it that way is $10,000 are there any
questions from the committee yes
representa luno thank you very much so
so and and thank you Miss Anders for for
um all the work you're doing not just as
superintendent but also as an advocate
for um for for real um costing and
funding for our for our Public Schools
but I think you you you you had a very
realistic observation in your comments
just now when when uh when you said hey
you know the state can't just
manufacture dollars it can plan ahead to
have dollars ready which it does every
two years in a in a budget cycle but I
can't just manufacture dollars and even
when the state plans ahead we talk with
people like Bruce canu and Keane from
from Department of Revenue
Administration that's a when you do
change something it's going to take that
amount of time for it to absolutely but
we don't have to change anything and
we've got $182 million sitting in the
education trust fund at the end of this
year what would you do with that well I
certainly wouldn't dump it into the
general fund I mean what what's what
that is
that that defeats the purpose of because
then you're going to end up I mean when
you start doing that you're going to end
up in a in a situation where you don't
have those dollars to tap into for other
obligations by the way that that the
legislature has created for for the
taxpayers so you have the the you have
the obligation of efas now those have
that that money has to be raised and
appropriated you have Charter School by
the way you're not meeting the
obligation to them
either I think we need to get back to
our business today right right so it's
so so you're talking about yeah the the
sheet that was handed out just yesterday
the sheet that came out yesterday from
Finance and I don't know if you got a
copy of it but there was enough copies
to go around and and um and and so
there's been some discussion about
amending bills to be able to dig into to
some of this and begin using using this
uh starting July 1st 2024 for the
upcoming school year is is that
something that that that we should be
looking at or should
we I think using it and emptying it are
two different different conversations
that's what I'm talking about using it
yeah for educ for for public school
purposes well I think you have to use it
to and and I'm and I'm sorry this
probably isn't what you want me to say
but you have to use that to meet the
obligations that you guys have have made
that by the way you hadn't raised an
appropriated for in the beginning you we
didn't raise an appropriate money for
efas where's that in the budget
let's get down to where we are with this
particular task today we're running out
of time here so if there no more
questions I'm going to take a break here
we're going to take a half hour lunch
here we got to stand up and walk around
then we want to come back and then we
got to move forward with suggesting
where are we going to go with these four
bills and I want to get that done today
so that we can get you know a mending
language done so we can have it proper
proper uh uh
action on the policy committee which
this is going to and then we'll we'll be
on our way thank you very
much par me I can't see this yeah it
would be according that time zone up
there it' be right around 20 of unless
somebody needs a little bit more time
12:45 12:45 12:45
okay round off thank you yeah we will
we'll get a
yes was
this
e
all this subcommittee back to order here
um and there was some discussion prior
to lunchtime if anybody got any lunch uh
that uh we look at the right hand side
of the column a little bit in terms
terms of fiscal capacity we had
discussion this morning about that not
really into a whole lot but there was
passing
discussion um does this group feel
comfortable moving forward with making
some changes on the base cost making
some recommendations regarding
differentiated Aid we haven't talked
swep yet either we need to talk that one
but are you are we also interested while
we're talking you know proposed needs or
changes to the funding for form
interested in talking about fiscal
capacity disparity a as it was reflected
in hb2 this last year that we're in
represent Ames well I definitely am I
think that uh on top of that the house
was uh when we went through the budget
process a year ago house position I
think was uh supportive of what you're
talking about fiscal the fiscal
disparity a component is what I'm
talking about and um it seems to fit it
uh the amount involved is about right so
it seems to fit into what we've been
talking about as a
one-time one-time input in future one
time and that was that was a hold over
from HB 1680 was it uh was that in 1680
repent
luno fiscal cap fiscal capacity bu in
1680 no it was no it
wasn't Aon Hennessy's was extraordinary
needs in9
yeah9 okay yeah uhhuh was also in what
we what we
brought I think to
division it was it was in the house past
version of hb2 and excised by the Senate
and since we didn't have a conference
committee that disc discussion was over
so let's throw it back to them yeah yeah
so I was just pulling up what was the
amount what was the amount for fiscal
capacity
me 77
million so it's the same order of
magnitude of what we were discussing
already this morning
so one of the things that go ahead one
of the things that continues to concern
me it's a data the sources of data um
and I know I'm like a broken record
about Hospital 601 and the direct
Medicaid certification if there was some
way to to get our data better and I I
know in my city of Manchester it really
matters we are not getting the people
aren't filling out the forms because
during covid they didn't have to so now
all of a sudden I I hear the school of
the school board chair you
know making all kinds of announcements
to parents please will you fill in those
forms so that that's been a concern of
mine and I know that Medicaid was skewed
previously because everybody pretty much
could be on Medicaid if they applied for
it but now those numbers I believe are
better if I'm I'm correct on that Mark
the the is the data better in that area
dfr data yes is moving closer to well we
would say status quo so pre pandemic um
so yes the data stabilized the
pmic reduction in counts because the
USDA W the data is
stabilizing good thank
you if we do have a I think we have a
bill that we have not acted upon that
deals with um
Medicaid personal identification of
information I think or something such
that but any rate I don't want to go in
that direction here right now my Lord we
have all this other stuff on our plate
yeah yeah okay um so fiscal capacity is
vared we're talking $70
million I'm looking for
it statement no
I I don't have my computer with me
either
Mark Mark do you have any information I
just wonder
that there you
go be careful
Margaret did you check the
bag
we won't go with that uh okay Mark do
you have any anything you could help us
out with in this discussion of fiscal
capacity dispari already now you're more
in a better
move back grounded on Earth
again uh yeah I'm just trying to go back
in time to what the house division 2
passed um and you guys the discussion as
far as the House and Senate negotiations
and then um uh I think your all your
Collective memory is is correct I'm just
trying to get the numbers um yeah it
looks like the amendment it was
Amendment 1170 that division 2 went with
um division 2 was interested
in increasing extraordinary needs Grant
above current
law uh I'm trying to find it's actually
hard to keep track of this but I believe
I believe with division 2's then we're
talking about the the budget here I
believe you were doing fiscal capacity
disparity Aid and I think you were doing
did you add just the fnr aid only I
think
that's
but but regardless of what you did back
then uh I think what the the
conversations I remember the house
division 2 having back then was um
extraordinary needs just to go back to
the two all the different Grant Vehicles
there's a lot of vehicles you can choose
to fund a lot lot of methodologies a lot
of ratios you can choose to fund
extraordinary needs is property over fnr
counts so it's your property values
relative to your fnr counts so it's
really only going to be targeted to
communities that have two things low
property values and high fnr counts it's
all relative speaking it's all based on
a Statewide average so that's how
extraordinary needs Grant works so
basically those two metrics relatively
speaking needs to be achieved um fiscal
capacity disparity Aid does not
consider fnr data it just goes students
over or sorry property over students
so it it it it it hits some different
communities it would fiscal capacity
disparity Aid is going to be hit some
communities that extraordinary needs
Grant does not so I think kind of just
throwing out maybe gtown as an example
but there's some communities where their
fnr numbers are average or below average
but their evpp is really low so their
fiscal capacity disparity aid grant is
going to be higher um where they're not
necessarily going to get hit with the
extraordinary needs Grant Target um so
and I believe what I how things ended up
um the house position previously was
that the house division 2 liked they
liked extraordinary needs grant for what
it did they liked uh I believe they
liked physical capacity disparity for
what it did and then they wanted one
metric that was just fnr only and so
just to go back to the progression of
time uh the 2021 one Aid component uh
there was $60 million that include
fiscal capacity disparity Aid which is
property values over pupils and then it
included f&r raid which just looked at
fnr ratios for each community and didn't
care about the property values within
those communities um that's
2021 um that was a onetime boost um then
um extraordinary needs Grant came into
effect in
23 um by that time fiscal capacity
disparity it had already expired um and
fnr additional Aid um was still in the
budget um it was um called relief Aid so
fiscal capacity disparity Aid we have
not seen that since 21 in the formula um
fnr focused Aid um we've seen that in
the budget uh in 21 we saw that in 22 as
relief Aid um and we don't see it in 23
and now the only sort of right side
grant that we have is extraordinary
needs Grant and so and the hold harmless
yes and stabilization gone yeah lot lots
happen but but um I the the the S of
policy discussion uh or policy
discussions that I I witnessed back when
all of you were considering that is all
these different mechanisms have
different targets that they're hitting
so extraordinary needs Grant um to some
extent Blends the targets because it
grabs property and fnr so it's sort of
taking it's more kind of efficiently
using one mechanism to describe two
phenomen
property and poverty um where the
different the different other programs
um isolate one metric and fund it
isolate one metric and fund it isolate
one metric and fund it um so those are
the those are the policy discussions I
remember you guys having um last
budget L yeah so thank you Mr chair and
thanks thanks Mark um yeah extraordinary
I think you described extraordinary
needs very well um but when you're when
you're when you're blending fiscal
capacity or you know uh property
valuation and poverty you're talking
about two different things you're
talking about a resource factor which is
property valuations and poverty is a
cost Factor so so so when you blend them
together it's it's you're you're you're
you're you're not addressing poverty
every place it is and you're not
addressing um access to property value
everywhere and your poverty uh metric is
already embedded in base adequacy I mean
in the differentiated age correct
correct so a pure play on the the
property value correction should be one
of the components in addition to base
adequacy and differentiated a correct
and and when I look back at it and I
think um Mr chair you were talking about
what what we were working on for hb2 was
based on a bill we worked on together
House Bill
529 that was yeah that's the bill so I
just found it and and at least my my
most recent um look at that your your
your memory is absolutely correct there
were two components to the quote right
side um of the of the formula a fiscal
capacity component which was a little
over $42 million almost $43 million and
then a and then an enhanced free
introduced lunch which is looks like
10.3 um million dollar so addressing
those two components uh
separately represent cordelli the other
thing uh the U I'm sorry
didn't I didn't realize yeah um I did
find a uh floor amendment to
hb2 um lad luno Emer and
Heath um Amendment 1285 H that has um
adjustments to the three components
fiscal disparity Aid extraordinary needs
and the relief Grant it has revised but
I I don't see a you know a total number
okay or fiscal not any kind associated
with the uh floor
amendment I want
toed I believe so I haven't checked it
on or anything I got uh just the
reference for what the house adopted
version of
hb2 uh is section 149 of
hb2 and that's fiscal it's called fiscal
disparity Aid what was the section
number again 149 okay now before that as
was mentioned um there were
calculations of what the formula that's
in that 149
produces and I'm sure that we can dig
that
up I don't know just what it
was well once again by addressing this
we do help on the other side of the
formula we don't help them all because
with property over top of fnr are some
of the or excuse me on fiscal cap
property over the
students some districts don't have many
students and so they're not really going
to get that but they are very poor
districts and they're required to
provide all the programming that another
one is and I think that captures a lot
of communities where I live and so
um one of the foundational things is
there's a geographic thing also in there
or size of school or something such as
that as a as a weighted Factor but see
we're not going there right now now so
um the I do have a number yeah okay
that's where it's going to go uh so that
the increase from current law proposed
by HB
529 fiscal capacity disparity Aid in
my computer here it's at 85.8 million
just for that one component y when we
when we did 529 then we prob it back yes
based
what what we had to work with Okay so
it's throttled back from
the conceptually can we just agree that
we want to reinstate the position of the
house whatever that was whatever that
quantity was and uh send that back to
the
Senate the way it landed uh in the final
house vote this spring this last
spring
well we we initially started out at
48 in the floor Amendment it was $4,000
per pupil
admr we couldn't get David we couldn't
get to the other side what happened with
towns like Berlin and those places
Rochester were coming out lower and
lower if we had the base higher but I
thought the base we did make a higher
base
in
compromise accept the governor's B I
believe we didn't accept the governor
4,800 ours was lower 4700 ours was lower
ours was lower than that I thought
according to this four
Amendment uh it was increased from
3561 to $4,000 per people okay yeah
4,000 right
yeah the 41 we put we put our emphasis
on the
right because then we adjusted because
that went into the charter school
funding and we adjusted that from the
nine it would have been $99,100 we
throttle that back to 9,000 for a Char
of school student that was all part of
the compromise
too what would happen if we left the
basee where it is at 4186 and then put
the difference of the
45 over in fiscal capacity rather than
in base adequacy I I I hear what you're
saying and you know that's where where I
you know that that that is an equity
driven result as opposed
to we not here
yeah and I think that's that's the
challenge when you put it you know if
you put it all towards the base it does
very little to for a whole lot of
places and put it on theity
side but I think the formula had was
Heavy F fnr because we we dumped in I
don't even remember how much of the last
minute was that we piled on the right
hand side and 80% of it went to
Nashville Manchester and Conquer it
didn't reach the outer banks that we
wanted to reach it it it reached places
that had high fnr and we couldn't get to
it unless we did put a stabilization in
we had a percentage of stabilization
that brought back like Berlin Rochester
really
been well yeah and and and that's why I
think on the 529 work we did we we went
with this disparity that was about four
times more than the than the fnr because
that reached out
to but but we also recogniz that we
hadre away
from don't we think the courts we just
to do something on the base I really
politically I think we're you know we
don't want to shoot ourselves in the
court I mean we're together for this
reason I think your approach is better
though I I would M with right now say
we're going to do it gradually and take
the two items that we discussed before
lunch and do those two steps and not not
try to make hanell happy right out of of
the gate well they're not going be happy
because we don't have that type of
dollar well what about breaking special
UC oh yeah saying all the things we
talked about before lunch those
amendments absolutely but I think and
then we rep your committee gets to
represent well they you're trying to do
it in a in a steep manner rather than
all of a sudden a giant the the the
weighted excuse me sorry the weighted
amounts there in the differentiated were
based off the
$444 base so that's upping the base from
where we are with 4186
now yeah yeah yeah you know if you if
your base goes up more then with the
limited dollars we probably have to go
with a lower factor for differentiate
Aid special ed well if you're not doing
anything in the
face
put but you know if you put it on the
right hand side of the
column that's
not that's not adequacy I
know
special education that's why I think
this weighted we got to do that but you
know if we have other money right now I
think we ought to put it on the base but
then also then
recommend that we conceptu recognize the
need for fiscal capacity disparity I
don't know if I have an exact figure we
should use that right whether it should
be 70 or you know we're creeping up to
over hundred
million2 you then you're exhausting that
yeah Mr chairman yeah just an effort to
reconcile a whole bunch of comments that
have already been said uh you're on a
type timeline you're looking to uh uh to
report to the floor and it's a two
commmittee bill so let's I would suggest
that go ahead and amend 1583 the way
you've proposed it it introduces the
categories it raises the levels both of
base adequacy and set it on uh the way
you had it July 1 125 as an effective
date get it to the floor get it past get
it to finance amend a different vehicle
putting inadequacy so they're riding in
two different bills and uh and and just
reinstate precisely what this house
approved you know last spring and get
that to the floor and then let Finance
have the luxury of another month to to
run numbers and figure out uh you know
what we can actually afford but but send
it to them with two different effective
dates so that we're on record as having
made the commitment on on base adequacy
and differentiated aid but we're
allowing for um stepping in the funding
commitment so I think that just takes
all the ideas that I've been hearing and
tries to say okay there's the ACT action
plan well that's good because that
narrows the
discussion
righty and it's
not manufact money got we know what's in
the account what would be in the account
going into to 25 and we can use we can
use a strong percentage of that
um you know and then by Design during
the next budget cycle
which that's where everything is up
to can I ask Mark a
question with regard to that Mark you
send your notices out to school
districts at what point for the
following year when do they find out
what how much what their allocation's
going to be so most districts um are
building their budget for fiscal year 25
they received that Revenue estimate in
November 15th so um a few months ago
they received the revenue estimates from
the state on how to build their 25
budget if you amend fiscal year 25 um
which has there's been it's been
happening the past few years amending uh
state law after the budgets local
budgets have been passed um they can do
a special district meeting to access
that money for the appropriation
purposes of spending on their schools or
they can um if they do nothing it lapses
to the taxpayers essentially it goes to
reduce their tax liability um for the
tax rates come December 2024 thank
you or we can considered a similar
Bill last week earli this
we
changes
St and
possibility represent cordelli yeah I I
based on a couple of things I've heard
um I I would hesitate on a
onee um only fixed we've run into so
many problems in the past when we do
something for one year and then um the
following year we get accused of cutting
um school funding or whatever the case
may be um two I'd like to see um a stay
in the ballpark of what we were talking
about this morning the 70
million um and third um you know I would
be just as happy I think not touching
adequacy given the current court case um
you know don't touch it and get you know
are we sticking our fingers in the pie
by touching
adequacy
yeah thank you I think I'd like to Echo
that is I a onetime thing is easy to get
used to and hard to get rid of and um I
think we need to remember that we're at
the very first step of a long process
and so we don't have to work out all the
details but we've got a general ballpark
where we're headed and I like the
direction that's going but I think that
those of us in the education committee
will be able to pick this up as soon as
it gets to our
committee to that end I think I think
the second committee on this Ways and
Means how are you going to fund it in
the future it's obvious we can Finance
can fund it in from the past so we're
like a rubber stamp mhm I I really think
Ways and Means is going to be on the hot
seat if this is going to be an ongoing
situation where the money G to come
from so before you go there dick dick
before you go so are you recommending
this be a one-time shot rather than no
I'm recommending if we're going to make
these changes they become permanent
changes but then you got to figure out
how you're going to pay for that that's
my position as well you
know and there is nothing worse when you
go back to the school district and you
start talking about what the budget's
going to look like when you know the
legislature just did a one-time thing
and you have absolutely no idea where
you're going to be next year and and I I
hear from many uh uh people in the
administration school board and um and
constituents they won't reduce the
property tax if they think it's only one
year because they're then going to start
start talking about what the ratchet
effect looks like in year two we we saw
that when we cut swep from 36 363
million to 263 million how many um
taxpayers got a reduction in their tax
bill I don't think there was
any you did we did
did that's because Sean Jasper comes
from
Huds and and when the when when the one
shot is fiscal capacity disparity a and
you're in a FIV Town district with five
different demographics and five
different uh uh consequences it is a
horrible debate so let's spare
them so let let's get a motion on and
take care of the part of this so far so
we can take
583 and amend 583 with those two
components which we talked about the
this morning the base cost going to 4404
and the weighted amounts per four
$444 by
those um percentage increases and I
don't have it right in front of me but
it went like 0
five6 was it first category a
category 1583 was the base cost
yes yeah so we will increase
increase from
4186 to
4404 just everyone remember to put your
keep your mics on because it'll be yeah
yeah special education to the three
categories per that per your sheet on
the with the that's right and the
category a is a
05 no wait a minute that's that's the
old sheet it's the one with a scribble
on it yeah okay 6 1 point2 8 yes that
sounds like it yeah because I doubled
the six to 12 and then we went up
another six to
18 so that that would
be on that one bill
1583 that's what we could recommend back
to the um full body the policy now the
ones that have to vote on then let's
let's make sure we're we're because we
want to make sure we got the effective
date on this effective July 1 vers
2024 I have no problems with that
okay that would go in
effect so with that so we can get
something done here the ones that can
vote on that are those from
the okay so we take caucus I have a
quickly question yes so the special ed
categories wouldn't wouldn't go to house
build 1656 the one on special ed no
we're going to use it for something else
we use that for something else got
it where you on that Glen huh where you
on that on on this that that I would
want to see if we're g to do something
else on
um turn off your
mic
caucus I think I think we're on board
with what you talked
about uh going to a base of uh oh sorry
um thank you Mr chair uh I believe we're
on board with what you talked about um
just after lunch uh amending 1583 to to
um to go to a a base of
444 having the three special education
categories weighted at6 1.2 1.8 and with
an effective date of uh July 1st 2024
and that total package would be about a
$70 million um uh package we also would
like to um to amend one of the um uh
other bills possibly 1656 or or put it
on top of
1583 to um to uh add um a fiscal
capacity disparity provision and I think
we need to take a look at what the
ranges are given what Mark has reported
out on the significant changes in
property valuation um but a fiscal dep
capacity disparity package of $50
million an enhanced free introduced
price lunch package of $25 million also
effective 71 2024 and that would be a
$75 million package so altogether we're
talking
$45 uh million out of the um estimated U
uh balance of the uh education trust
fund on
630 Al righty
um I think you're too
rich can't sustain
it so so thank thank you I mean I think
the
sustainability of uh of that obviously
has a lot to do with the next budget
cycle and there's a lot of things that I
think go into you know the um the the
budget cycle with respect to
sustainability of all state operations
so we had we had some discussion on this
and I think maybe to a little bit too
rich here but where where we are I think
there's concurrence and agreement
regarding the special education
differentiated Aid I think everybody's
on board with increasing that at the
amount of
uh5 I'm trying to read the which sheet
it's got buried here 35 million a little
over $35
million um and
[Music]
to consider also in the fiscal capacity
disparity or fiscal cap in and what bill
was that in Mark the 39
million in House Bill Bill two we had
fiscal capacity disparity Aid in the
amount of 39 in it we'd like to see that
side of the formula done effective July
1 2024 and the uh area de with special
education totaling up you know about 74
million and then writing in that
effective at
the you
know what was be July 1
2025 that the amount of 4404 would be
the
base
Sugg the base for fy2 they should stay
the
same and I I'll just give you a little
more information on that and leaving the
special education money set the way
we've got it on paper right here that
was develop developed off
4444 leave that and and just have that
you know inclusive in that amounts for
each weighted the dollar the dollars and
to put the
4,44 base cost and increment over the
4,100 plus we have right now to start in
July 1
125 and the fiscal capacity which would
be the 39 billion million that we took
out of hb2 plus the 35 here for July 1
starting that's that's where we what did
you have again for the for the right
side that was 39 Mark
39 on which of the two components fiscal
disparity a so that would be
39 million and then anything on pre
no so would be 74 million effective
21 uh
7124 and then the base adequacy for
approximately 34 million
7125 Mr chair is it possible to have
Mark run what we
so
number the policy that's been used with
capacity is you're always going to aim
for not know if it's average or median
but it's going to it's going to start at
the floor so who's ever got the lowest
this is
thec always
follow the highest rant award is always
going to go to the community generally
with the lowest EV and then it's going
to slowly pH out you the average and so
give or take move the numbers around a
little bit um if you tell me you want to
spend 39 million I can essentially say
okay well then how would I distribute
that in a way where that the community
that has the lowest tax base gets the
biggest brand award and the community
with the median median gets essentially
zero or you small amount of dollars
right that's what we've done yeah
yeah so that's so we got to
move here on on this are are is that
good with y'all um no I think I think
we're interested in putting forth our
versions of of these
amendments
can can you pro pro present both options
to the education
committee one thing I hate to see it
come out 10 10 and the education
committee because then we get this big
issue on the floor be good if we can get
this to our second
committee without a whole lot of
hassle then because it's going to have
to come back to the house floor so yeah
then could could we do this could we
could we put the two um the two versions
of the these could all be on
one using
1583 right
sure for your version of a 53 am 1583
Amendment and the Democrat
version get those get those two
amendments on top of
1583 and and have the note Department
generated
you for that and then and then take it
to committee it
around agree it would be great to have
committee rally around one of those
and then and then uh interim study the
other three bills well we interim study
that we haven't discussed the we that
tall yeah
yeah certainly the other the other right
yeah but I I want to make real clear
here this we they' said this is a
Band-Aid it's a continued
Band-Aid 1586 looks at a total look it's
really a restructure
of how we fund schools and I want a
commitment a commitment to look at this
seriously it's been four years since we
put this forward the first year we
couldn't even get anybody talking about
it and frankly probably the reason why
we're talking about it now is because of
a damn court
case so I'm not going to leave this
committee until there's a there's a damn
commitment I'm sorry calm down sorry
GL that we that we are committed that
over the summertime that we're going to
look at 1586 in a serious way so that by
the time we come to create a new budget
next time we at least have got something
that that hopefully is going to address
and by that time we should know what the
Court's going to say eta so so I guess
Mr chair I'm asking a commitment on your
part to continue a serious C study of
this if we in fact put this in interim
study 1586 in the interim study if if we
have an interim study I would hope that
we could have the same
composition and and uh have a serious
look yes I would I'm not going to
guarantee that any Bill comes out the
way we're looking at it you know that's
that's up to the committee and keep and
keep this group together as many as that
are available right to do
it mean I have to change my Alaska bit
is it this
summer go in August go in August that's
a rainy season if there's awful up there
June's the best season to visit Alaska
um yeah but I yes I would I'm certainly
good with that
but you you you're you still you're
You're Going For
What 100 145
145 see we're we're we're going for 74
so there significant difference
there
yes can you explain to me why only 70
and not 145 if the money we're talking
about the money that's budgeted in the
education trust fund
correct yeah this 14 145
million why wouldn't we want to expend
that let the finance people maybe
somebody
can you can only spend it
once you don't you don't have
endlessly so it goes to Ways and Means
and say you got another 145 and they say
yay nay whatever we're going to have to
do this and that something else and they
can say no we
don't the difference the delta right now
and the education trust fund is about
$40 million a
year all right so we're suggesting
spending 70 ongoing which is greater
than the 40 so now we go look at Ways
and Means and say we got to come up
under the 30 you're proposing to say you
got to come up with another hund
whatever I I don't know what the math is
well yeah that's right sure but we're
only looking at one one one side of it
right now the education trust fund the
general fund is the um you know is the
the big enchilada and what is the
Surplus statement look like for the for
the general
fund right now I think it's uh over 250
yeah so so the general fund is is is
generating revenues over over plan over
plan yes so
so that certainly seems like it would be
enough to cover I mean we're we're we're
talking about $75 million difference
right in what you're B yeah so the the
general fund is is generating surpluses
well ahead of what we're suggesting to
be used for Education which in the in
the
state's discretionary spend is the
biggest portion of the of the of its
discretionary I just want to say that
when we make a commitment we have to do
it for school districts we can't tell
them they're going to get XYZ and then
have to reneg on that it's not feir to
taxpayers it's not feir to school
districts they do their budgets almost a
year ahead so we've got to this is a
commitment and a promise and we can't
defer from
that Mr
chairman we're talking about virtually
the same package and virtually the same
numbers and the difference is how we
phase it in and we heard a difference uh
in in posture earlier is it a one shot
is that a
Band-Aid I'd like to make this a
commitment that is not a oneshot and
it's not just a Band-Aid it's a first
step towards and I think yeah I would
like to certainly be on record that I
hope any vote to put 1586 in interim
study is a sincere effort to prepare uh
the legislature for
2025 um budget cycle okay so in that
context I think since we're saying
virtually the same thing and and you're
hearing input from ways and means we
don't have a vote and
finance uh that the best way to get this
done is to stagger uh this is the spirit
and the purpose of the uh the way that
representative Vlad laid it out to do
the things that you want to do in two
steps and then stick with it
and work on 1586 and I think if you look
at it like that holistically it makes
sense I
appreciate I appreciate that schools um
I I just think when we when we take a
look at the um
the the changes that that you got that
you're proposing to make and introduce
uh for fy2 and the changes we're
proposing to to make and introduce for
FY
25 not just not just the the the the
total dollar but the effect that it has
on school on on on on so many more
school districts in a in a meaningful
full way is going to be really important
because I agree I think we're we're not
that far off in our in our general scope
on this but but if we were to get from
the Department um to see what the
difference is and see what that means I
mean the the you know I I think we're
talking about good changes for special
education uh and and a good change to
the to the base as well but those two
changes don't do anything you know more
for um Newport than they do for
Newcastle and when we look at the other
things that we're proposing we're
talking about things that are going to
do a lot for Newport and a lot for
Claremont and Berlin and a lot of the
other towns that have have really been
suffering for the last 30 plus years um
uh in this and it's not a solution it's
a Band-Aid because everything on the
right hand side is to fix everything
that's broken or things that are broken
on the leftand side of the formula and
one of the real positives around 1586
and I think 1586 can be shuffled around
a lot of different ways and Dick been
just in the last week been looking at a
couple of couple of of significant
changes to that can be done in a way
where it's a strong adequacy formula
that doesn't require to be propped up
with a bunch of rightand side you know
bandages and braces and everything else
um so I i' I'd like to I'd like to see
us proceed with with the two amendments
um in in in in a form enough that that
the department could could could run
some numbers and then maybe as a group
we can we could reconvene you know it
doesn't have to be for four hours on a
Friday maybe it's for a half hour you
know when when all of our committees are
meeting or something like that or maybe
it is I think the next two Fridays we
don't have task
force I mean High Ed yeah yeah we don't
have highered task force so and I know
we got to be out and done by the uh by
the thir 13th we're going to exec these
so um but you know to to so that so that
at least we're looking eyes wide open at
at what it all what it all
means well I I think what we've got to
do is just have another short caucus we
have we have not really coau we wer in
here
discussing so why don't we take a moment
or two and do that and so we need to
clear the room out of everybody but
people on the committee here
okay
e
uh let me explain what uh we'd like to
do um we would like to I think we have
General consensus from everybody here
that about the special
education so we think it's probably
appropriate that we put the special
education on a separate bill on
1656 and it would be as it's been
presented to us earlier this morning the
based on the 4404 and the weighted
factors of uh
6 um
1.2 and
1.8 so that's one the other other way
would like to do is to take the bill
which is the
1583 that's the one dealing with the uh
the base and it opportunity for an
adequate
education and also adding on that by way
of an amendment uh amending it to
include fiscal capacity disparity
Aid in the amount you know we really
didn't talk numbers but basing upon what
we heard the $39 million putting that on
that and also Al having the 4404 as the
base on it and have the deadline for uh
implementation on the fiscal capacity
disparity date as uh 1 July
2024 and
the implementation of the base cost at 1
July
okay so you got the special ed one right
special separate number
1656 and that is the bill which came
about special ed that is the bill and
then we want to take 1583 that's the one
that um deals with the base cost we
would like to also put into that bill uh
the issue that we feel that the right
hand side of the column has to be looked
at with fiscal capacity capacity
disparity Aid as was reflected in
hb2 and that's a $39 million
tab stays on the left hand side on the
right hand side right hand side and then
effective that would be effective July 1
2024 we'd have two effective dates
within that bill the the second part of
the bill would be the increase the base
cost to 4,44 and that would be effective
July 1
2025 so for for what I'm hearing and I I
appreciate uh that very much um uh I
think we're close I think um i' I'd
still like to see us create um two you
know two amendments on on each of these
bills and I think we can we can
structure them the same way that you're
talking about so that we would have an
amendment to well we we actually we both
be be full agreement on on 1656 15 1656
we're both we're all on the same page on
that and then an amendment on
1583 I think we would like to see a base
of
4404 and a fiscal capacity disparity U
Aid of 50 million and an effect and an
enhanced free underdose Price lunch of
25 uh million all effective
7124 which was the 25 million that was
the enhanced free this is what we'
worked on together on House Bill 529 so
start over around 1583 want have I
wasn't writing now I thought I knew
where you're going you you strayed on of
me so no we were fiscal capacity
disparity Aid of 50 million yeah 50
million and then the free and reduced
price
lunch U additional Grant of 25 million
so that's the $75
million Equity
package and having both those um
ring in on 7124 I mean you've got you've
got a $40 million fiscal capacity
disparity Aid 39 million on 7124 so
we're fairly close on that we're
essentially off by um $36
million I think if is that going to
appear in the bill is that going to f in
the fisc note just just the policy
going um no the the the the policy would
be there would be two
amendments no but I'm saying are put the
dollars in the bill or
just the policy and let fiscal note
cover the dollars the fiscal note would
cover the dollars because it's coming
out of the education trust fund uh we we
don't have to generate cash uh for this
year because because we've got it but
but it would be incumbent during the
budget process of next year if the
policy was to remain we wouldn't have
the policy sunset but if the policy was
to remain the same then it would be up
to to budget next year to make sure that
or or change the policy so so is this is
this a commitment though to continue
this
yes so exactly what type of dollar sign
are you looking for for going effective
July 1 2024 it would be 9 million 145
million oh okay and you're at you're at
because you you're subtracting out 35
though for the special
ed uh no we oh oh sure yeah yeah so
we're both agreeing on the special ad
right yeah so yeah so
um yeah yeah so 110 109 110 million
um and you're so we're at that for the
for that one and you're at at um 39 plus
whatever the whatever the 4404 costs
beginning
correct which is which is6 million for
every
$100 right so it's
$300 so that's that's 45 Mill U 45
million something like
that let me get this straight because
on the second Bill we're talking about
we're talking
about putting in you're talking about
the base right we're we're talking and
that is 34 million that's 34 million
yeah and then we're talking
about you said
fnr so talking about base of 34 million
that's base of 4404 yeah it's 34 million
plus fiscal capacity disparity Aid of
5050 million why not the
39 well let me let's let's talk the
whole thing and then a free and reduced
price lunch at
25 I
mean you you I mean Rick you know I'm a
transactional based guy on on this type
of on this type of stuff and if if we're
close let's let's let's get close but if
you're willing to do free introduced
price launch and we know how much free
introduced price launch is a cost Factor
um then I'm not going to quibble and me
Mel can kick me under the table I
wouldn't quibble on on 10 or 11 million
on fiscal capacity disparity I mean I I
don't have permission to say the only
difference you want that the whole
package 7124 everything
7124 so that totals up to what 98
million 34 39 25
yep
par me plus the plus the
35 but that's SE I me sorry plus the 45
separate bill y y yes right yeah it's
coming out of the same it's the same
package Terry Terry's right yeah
yeah I think we're still way apart we're
not that far apart yeah we
are just change the base increase to to
25 that's why we have
Mark do the comparison you see exactly
side by side
almost I think
you're TR TR Tracy's on to a good
thought on
that the other on 24 and just the base
move off to
25 so everything else you want goes into
24 so so so base would
be 7
125 um phisical capacity disparity Aid
of I'm just going to round 39 up to 40
million 7124 right free introduced price
lunch at 25
7124 and the special education category
7120 correct I think we're really
close I vot so no no but I mean but
you're yeah yeah your vote counts in the
next committee
so yeah yeah well that I think that's
more palatable so it doesn't Wipe Out
the the whole
fund what is the bottom line total
amount of money work when chasing from
the trust
fund uh it would be so we
came down 10 off that and
um and 45 so 55 so uh we were at 140 so
we're that would be 90 in the in the
first year and then
45 plus the
N the the base wouldn't wouldn't come
off in the first year so it would be I
think it would be 90 it looks like in
the first
year don't forg already budged the
second
year already so
adding making up that 90 break down the
90 for me the 90 would be um 35 um 40 m
I'm just using numbers that end in zeros
pretty much fiscal capacity disparity of
$40 million
391 40 million 40 million free
introduced price lunch 25
million um
special
education 35
million is that up to 90
10 yeah yeah 100 yeah good because I I
wasn't looking at the numbers I
was 7124 for
yeah yeah yeah yeah and and and and and
yeah and some real important things that
that none of this presses into the home
hold
harmless only extraordinary needs
presses in to hold harmless this doesn't
not Penny of this presses in to hold
harmless sure you're not talked about
the base at all base base will will will
push up off to
7125 and and that's going to be subject
to the next budget anyway so you know
int there and a REV yeah who knows what
so could get down to 99 if you had the
fiscal disp disparity at at 39 like they
were told don't round it up don't round
it up I'm okay I'm yeah I'm okay yeah I
was just I was just using numbers and
zeros yeah I know we just numbers are
easy when they're not yours huh it's not
coming out of your pocket well it it is
it's all coming out of our pocket I said
your pocket yeah
soy here I just want to where did the
free and reduced come from because
that's the first time that's been
introduced into no we we um represent
lad and I worked on this we we've worked
on this together for many many years
going back to 2019 I think and um and
the the the the the the evidence behind
the costs associated with with with um
uh providing instruction and and and
educational outcomes for students that
come from low-income families comes
directly out of the work we did on the
study commission but um but it also came
out of uh out of work we did together on
House Bill 709 and on House Bill 529
that went into the budget that was later
ripped out in the uh in the Senate so
when you're talking about the fnr you're
talking about taking it in the
differentiated a category or on the
right hand side on the right hand side
yeah so
in effective
7124 we are looking at $74 million the
special ed plus the free and
reduced and you're looking at in 7124
uh the free and reduced the
fnr and the special ed for let's say one
98 99 I think let's not chip another
million yes right what's a million
dollar here and there um clarify that I
think you said that our position was the
free and reduced but it was the um
fiscal capacity disparity a I had both
fiscal disparity a was the 39 was the 39
plus free and reduced
25 yeah
okay so
that's we're basically at 74 and you're
basically at 99 for uh uh F year well
hold on we no we're we're not at 99
unless you're at 99 um oh okay yeah so
um we we'll we'll want right but right
that at the moment that's where we are
well we only came down to you know we
gave up we gave up base to
25 if and we gave up fiscal capacity
disparity from 50 to 39 um with your
agreement to add free introduced price
lunch the expanded FRP on the right hand
side to 25 right so you're if if we come
to uh that could be a common shaking of
hands on that you're at 99 for Effective
7124 and we're um we're at 74 no be at
99 on I'm sorry right we'd both be at 99
99 we we can shake hands if and the base
in in 25 correct
right as well as um both in agreement on
special correct
yeah okay
go you on no more talking yeah it's a
Friday afternoon get it over with
okay I I think were you on
that excuse me I'm just pointing out the
25 away from 99 puts us exactly the same
I'm just the free reduced um is is has a
background that just reappeared and I'm
just a little bit behind on
that yeah I mean you know Cher lad you
can you speak to this as well as anybody
on on
the
cost of Education
with yeah it's a it's an important area
that helps the towns which are needing
it your town I I get that I'm just
saying that that wasn't in any of my
notes coming up to right now
yeah that was part of hb2 I think it was
yeah it was hb2 part hb2 that we were
talking about so we're we're I think
that we're at at a point where we can
take something back to the committee as
a whole and let it be decided there um
so all those in favor of a
recommendation I'll read it 39 for um
fiscal disparity
Aid 25 for fnr and 35 for special
education weighted values all to be done
by
7124 and then the base of 4404 and 7125
right and then the and the we already
said the the the special education are
calculated against the
4404 so the the 35 so the
34 which is the
4404 is recommended for july25 correct y
say it again I just said the the instead
of saying 4404 I was also saying that $
34.3 million is what it adds up to as an
increase that will be done that involves
the 4404 from
4182 um that that would occur in July 1
2025 correct yeah
so okay let's have a a vote on that from
the par me yeah yeah Mark will do a full
Mark will'll do the numbers by 10 well
that that yeah but that's not
that's
explain so what you're doing
here focusing on the policy yes first
you got decide what I give you
some yep that's right that we'll vote on
the policy side of it and and and and
just from a I I thought the way mark
laid out the policy particularly on on
um fiscal capacity disparity uh looking
at at what whatever the low EVP is and
what evpp and whatever the median evpp
is and um median the average or
or
average yeah I think that's what we did
too yeah yeah yeah and then you put 39
million on
that yep yep yep and um and then free
and reduced price lunch actually you you
did the numbers when we when we did the
budget so it would look very similar to
that be 25 so double whatever got great
okay so let's let's take a vote of the
education committee members
only going around the
tables the roll call we don't have to do
that in the
subcommittee yeah it we're not going to
do that
here we're on so let's walk around the
table from uh represent
dry Reon
cascaden yes represent luno represent
Miler represent cordelli yes
representative dry
represent lad
yes so we have a recommendation to take
back to the committee the other thing we
have to look at here is have a motion on
15 1686 this is on
the the uh no it's I like to establish a
foundation op that one
1586 and I think we're all in
concurrence that we do a conscientious
job of interim study on that and and and
get down and start as soon as possible
and look at the total gamut of funding
education they're all due and we will be
voting on the report in November so so
the dates are already down in the
calendar so interim study is something
that's we don't decide the dates they're
already done by the house 1586 168
so oh Oh I thought you were sorry 1586
1586 yeah yeah we're in study right yeah
so let's take let's take uh a vote on
that are you ready to go first time okay
yes represent cordelli yes represent
Miler represent Luna yes represent
cascaden yes and represent lad yes so
that we're unanimous on
that leaves one more bill
here um six
swep I move
itl
second you unfortunately you you're not
allowed to vote um I want to have a
discussion first than
that because we haven't discussed it
yet so um we know that the excess swep
is a little less than 30 million
rejected out the year after that
somewhere around 26 I can't recall Mark
you know those numbers better than
anybody here um so concept is that the I
think the way we're looking at it that
the town still collects it but has to
return the access to to the treasury or
to Department I don't
know to the treasury yeah how the bill
read the bill reads that it all goes to
the treasury and then makes dispersement
back to the
town no no the bill reads the
excess no
16 1686 is just excess so the excess is
returned yeah 1586 was okay sorry
yeah okay
so so we we have that to deal with know
that we're also going to be talking
about this in
1586 right so it's incorporated into
that discussion as well so it's in
actually two places within what we have
to do here um 1686
is it's going to be you know vote your
conscience or what your town wants you
to do I think more than party but at any
rate yeah
I think that's about 27 27 of us that be
so so let me let me let me float float
float an idea you have a lot of people
though in that number of towns let me
float an idea in
1686 and and and you know I I I do not
agree with the um Coalition Community
position that um that that that
they shouldn't have to contribute
towards the state tax that's used to
fund education and that by if they were
to contribute to such a fund that they
would would the towns would be owed some
level of accountability on the use of a
state tax I I I just don't agree that
last part I have you know because state
tax the state deserves accountability
but but the towns don't um and
and but if the if
the if a portion of the concern over a
over a Statewide property tax is for its
use in education then as an alternative
could it be deposited into the
general to be used for roads
Bridges that's good
question would that be more
more no it's disappearing from the town
it doesn't matter what it USS for it's
the paper
right I'd be willing to put an amendment
that the excess stays with the town but
it has to be used for educational
purposes Mr chairman there was a bill
that I handed out I can't put my hands
on it which was
hb77 and I can't find it in this mass of
paperwork here but there was one we
introduced represent so so the the
premise of
hb6 uh
86 is to deal with a constitutional
problem that has to do with Equitable
funding of education so redirecting the
exess to Bridges and
Roads you're talking about
depi
I see
okay yeah well a deeper discussion of
swept for another day i' I'd love to
join in but right now if we're just
talking about the
excess um it's clearly got to be for
education
purposes here here's an amendment which
we once had an HB
337 and this was
dated uh back in
2009 have representative hes Flanigan
lad Kirk Benton court and Jaspers
oldtimers and it reads as follows a
municipality May remit the balance of
such excess or any portion there thereof
to the Department of Revenue
Administration as provided in this
paragraph or retain the balance of such
excess to be used in the current fiscal
year or a future fiscal year to offset
the costs of school building
construction or renovation project or to
offset catastrophic special education
costs incurred provided that not
withstanding the eligibility Provisions
set forth in RSA
1985a through 19815 h 19815 u through uh
19815 W we're talking about building Aid
there I think uh and 186 c18 the
municipality shall exhaust such excess
as a condition of eligibility for school
building Aid alternative school building
Aid or catastrophic special education
Aid so what I was basically trying to do
is say you use it for those specific
purposes it could be expanded to make
sure it's used for Education can I
comment on that but those non excess
swept towns will not have that you know
I live in the city of Manchester the
city of Manchester
generates a large amount of money in
terms of lotto in terms of Kino in terms
of any number we don't say we generate
those monies so we want to keep them all
we they go out to the state and they're
used for the roads they're used for all
different purposes so places like the
city of Manchester and Nashua why should
we be penalized and the people that
can re raise more than they need to
raise for swep are allowed to keep it
for those purposes that means that we're
going to get a double whimy with a
building Aid because we don't get it
anyway and now you really won't get
it any further discussion on it rips and
hes um I guess two things one is the
FYI there is a uh another swep bill that
uh came to the house floor a few weeks
ago on the consent calendar and uh then
was referred for interim study to Ways
and Means and that bill um sends all
collected re revenue from the swept tax
to the Dr for depositing the education
trust fund less a 3% processing fee
that's allowed to the
municipalities and then also has a uh uh
changes in the hormonal low and moderate
income um what's it rebate program um
and uh uh so so that's been returned
it's an interim study in ways and means
uh we'll see what happens with it it's a
bill that I sponsored uh that's been
hanging around for quite a while um it's
it's essentially the same as what's in
the back of
hp5
um just so you know there is an interim
study on this same subject were you the
first committee to receive it or did go
to another
committee first committee first me and
then um the other comment is that I
think
uh on this legal
issue that
um well I just Express an opinion the
likelihood is that this part of uh Rua's
work on school funding um is uh likely
to be approved um I say that based
on you know just my understanding of the
law and uh others others input um
ardener uh Mr ardinger um feels very
strongly along those lines and uh shared
his views with Ways and Means which is
part of the reason why we went into
interim study on this um and I think any
bill
that that tries to retain for the
locality where the money was generated
in any any way or
form is going to trespass on the notion
that this is a state tax needs to go for
Statewide purposes and not be
essentially rebated to the taxpayers who
generated it because that that's the
inequality that's the lack of
proportionality that uh that U um makes
the whole uh swept model with the
provision allowing retention
um unconstitutional in the views of many
and uh you know so take that for what
it's worth everybody has an opinion on
what's constitutional what's not um and
I think uh there's a good chance that in
this case uh this swep tax with the
retention of excess swept is is headed
for a definitive and final ruling that
it's
unconstitutional uh so we need if that's
the case we need to figure out what to
do with it is not really a school
funding issue right now um and uh uh it
uh is a taxpayer issue um so there's
some time to work on it
what's five do you have 569 569 sounds
good got five and a n I'm not sure about
the middle
digit dick could you also talk a little
bit about um how the um how the order on
on um on Rand what the timing is for
that um well it's been
appealed so everything's on hold stayed
so it's it's not it can't happen it's
getting you know it's really gotten to
the point where it's too late going
through this next cycle
we're into that cycle so um who knows
when the court will get to it and when
they do it's going to have to impact on
the next time around and um you know
presumably the general court the
legislature will respond
and do something but basically that's
the kind of thing that I think the
courts better suited to uh to get in the
way of uh a law than uh than school
funding is school funding is more
complicated and involves imp
Appropriations this is just saying you
can't do it this way
1686 oh I see
um yeah yeah it would if if uh if what's
in 1586 were to
pass that would send all the money
collected to the state and that's the
issue 1686 would also
probably uh be sufficient uh there's
some question about how you calculate
EXs weep because you don't really know
for sure until all the numbers all the
collections have happened and so forth
but that's a Nuance so yeah I'd say
probably yes
rcad just just to add to that a little
bit the summary judgment was ruled on
for SWAT correct and it requires a
uniform rate I'm not hearing anybody
talk about setting a uniform rate we're
only talking about excess monies don't
we have to do both no no there the lack
of a a uniform rate deres from the
sending um from the
retention of the excess money by the
municipality so so in effect it's it's
money coming back to the same taxpayers
that generated that paid a122
per uh thousand and now they're getting
back 22 let's 22 cents per th000 because
that excess swep actually was put back
into their
pot something like that I don't know I'm
just is is that clear the122 is the
uniform rate it's then adjusted based on
unequalized valuation it's this uh
retention of the excess that distorts
that and that's the practice that as as
Davis
suggested we've got bills that hit this
issue in three different ways any one of
which in my opinion would moot that
specific claim while the rest of the
litigation uh you know continued on to
appear yes uh represent
to
okay we all want to get out of here so
maybe we have just go around the table
and sort of
get this bill right here I don't think
for me adds up to the importance of the
other bills we're doing but but it's
important I know it it's
money so represent
Dr so a vote now would be to just send
it the way it is to our committee is
that
correct yeah okay and when would we
address the fact that there are other
times that a negative tax rate can be
set that don't have to do with education
funding I I didn't hear you I'm sorry
there's this says prohibits tax uh Dr
from setting negative local and County
tax rates on real property and we just
heard last time that there are cases
where that happens organically that have
no relation to
swept we didn't talk about that we had
Dr talks somewhat about it at the
initial part I don't know if we're going
to fix that here in this policy that's
thatly why I'm saying so just send it on
to our committee and me then just send
it on to our I think we need to send
this right just to the committee and let
the committee as a whole make a
recommendation on this one okay
everybody's going to be voting what
their Community wants them to
vote and I I I think for us to try and
do something right now is that we'll
just bring it to the back to the
education committee and say there was no
recommendation from the committee we'll
open up that great discussion there and
sit there for three or four hours
discussing
it Joy yeah so ra
and I don't know where it's going to end
up I have no idea where that's going to
end up I'm sort of betwix and between it
myself yeah I'm coming from one of those
property poor towns but I don't like the
idea of taking money away from the
community either if they're really
basing their their income and attracting
business as a result of uh having lower
level of Taxation i a
not collect money that goes up for the
pluming
bridge I know it when I lived over in
Maine that's where do you think they got
all their money from Cape Elizabeth
where they had the power plant and
spread that all over the
state what a common good we call CBR
seabook yes seab Brook here okay well I
don't I think we've made recommendations
that as far as we're going to go with
this committee and I I want to thank
thank everybody taking a Friday
afternoons for this or mornings as well
but I think our work is concluded and
thank you very much and
we'll well even maybe you know if if
maybe even if we have like a couple
weeks or so later on in to Spring before
we have no bills might made that
commment to the people of New Hampshire
that we would continue this journey
y okay so thank you very much thank you
have have a good afternoon
everybody I gotta go home watch St lence
play
RIT
yeah